bien mes chers collègues je vous invite
à rejoindre vos places
nous allons donc débuter notre réunion
de commission et singulièrement
l'audition
de deux ministres mises à l'intérieur
d'outre-mer monsieur Darmanin puis le
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion Monsieur Olivier du choc
ils sont cet après-midi devant notre
commission au moment où le texte sur
l'immigration va venir en débat quelque
temps avant quand même puisque je
rappelle que la science publique est
prévue à partir du 27 mars prochain mais
qu'évidemment préalablement nous aurons
le rapport de nos rapporteurs nos deux
rapporteurs madame Jourda et Monsieur
Philippe bonnecarère en commission et
singulièrement un certain nombre
d'amendements que j'imagine en
préparation monsieur les ministres je
tiens à vous signaler que nous sommes en
retransmission directe sur Public Sénat
et probablement sur le site internet du
Sénat ce qui fait que cette audition a
un caractère qui va public au-delà même
de notre éminents commissaires qui sont
présents
et je vais sans tarder vous donner la
parole dans l'ordre que vous souhaitez
c'est peut-être vous monsieur Darmanin
qui débuterez
ensuite je proposerai à Madame Jourda et
Monsieur bonnecarraire de vous poser des
questions nous allons vous y répondrez
et puis les collègues qui voudront
s'exprimer le front bien sûr tout en se
signalant comme d'habitude
auprès de nous pour qu'on puisse
enregistrer les demandes de parole voilà
merci de votre présence et monsieur le
ministre vous avez la parole merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur ministre
cher Olivier madame monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis très heureux avec mon
collègue et Amy Olivier du sol d'être
devant votre commission pour commencer
l'étude du texte proposé par le
gouvernement sur la situation migratoire
et sur les moyens que le gouvernement
pourrait se donner à la suite de la Love
Me y reviendrons puisque ce n'est pas un
texte là de moyen c'est un texte
législatif mais les moyens ont été votés
par le Sénat notamment je remercie sur
la loi de modernisation du ministère de
l'Intérieur pour essayer d'être au
rendez-vous des capacités que donnons
dans la révolution pour les préfectures
comme pour l'intégration pour évoquer
cette situation migratoire que le Sénat
depuis longtemps appellent de ses vœux
une réponse forte et de réponse
évidemment au rendez-vous des enjeux ces
enjeux ils sont très importants je vois
d'abord rappeler que la situation
internationale c'est-à-dire les guerres
et les dictatures qui se multiplient sur
les théâtres du monde les persécutions
qu'elles soient religieuses ou sexuelles
les difficultés économiques et sociales
que notre pays est
évidemment est partagé par beaucoup de
pays en développement notamment depuis
le covid et puis bien sûr le changement
climatique font peser sur l'Europe et
sur la France une pression migratoire
très importante
tellement importante que elle ne se
vérifie pas depuis ces derniers mois ou
depuis la situation du covid comme je le
lis parfois je voudrais souligner
demande d'asile a été multipliée par
deux en disant et que la demande d'asile
a été multipliée par 3 depuis 2007 rien
que de l'année 2022 qui continue cette
augmentation des immigrations et
notamment d'immigration dites de
protection la hausse de toute l'Union
européenne des demandes d'Asie en 2022
c'est plus
61%. je pourrais constater qu'en France
ce n'est que je mets évidemment des
guillemets que
31%, mais nous avons atteint le pic
historique de 2019 138000 demandes
d'asile en 2022 et donc nous retrouvons
évidemment des chiffres qui
correspondent aux crises migratoires
précédentes et rien ne peut penser que
cela s'arrêtera dans dans les mois et
dans les années qui viennent pour tout
le continent européen
la comparaison avec les années
fin des années 90 et début 2000 n'a plus
beaucoup de sens je rappelle que la
plupart des pays d'immigration et
demandeur d'asile par exemple ce soit la
Syrie la Libye l'Afghanistan mais aussi
tous les pays de la bande saelo
saharienne n'était pas dans le chaos
politique et terroriste que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui la France comme
l'Europe avait des relations
guillaumatiques fortes avec ces pays ce
qui n'est plus le cas pour une partie
d'entre eux je ne parle évidemment pas
de ce qui se passe encore très récemment
en Iran on a aussi pensé pendant très
longtemps dans les politiques publiques
que les gouvernements menés qui soient
droits de gauche que le développement
économique notamment du continent
africain freinerait l'immigration et
force cette constater aujourd'hui que
chacun le constate que le développement
économique du continent africain
notamment ne freine pas l'immigration
mais la tendance à même l'encourager
puisqu'une partie de la classe devenue
moyenne dans certains pays d'immigration
historiques fait que vers l'Europe vers
les États-Unis vers l'Occident les gens
soient prennent les moyens du
déménagement au fond déménager une
partie de leurs enfants ou de leurs
parents pour qu'il trouve un avenir
meilleur il y a donc une situation
difficile à obtenir pour l'Europe à la
fois des crises qui font naître des
départs et puis en même temps un
développement qui fait aussi naître des
départs que c'est aussi par une
démographie importante
le débat en France comme partout en
Europe n'est pas donc des pour ou contre
l'immigration immigration est un fait
c'est une réalité qui touche tous les
pays quel que soit leur régime politique
que soit l'opinion de leur dirigeants et
comme le disait le Général de Gaulle il
n'y a pas de politique en dehors des
réalités c'est donc c'est la réalité que
nous regardez en face en revanche un
grand continent comme l'Europe un grand
pays comme la France doit répondre à
trois questions ces trois questions sont
sans doute le nœud grandir de notre
débat et les 27 articles que propose de
ce projet de loi apporte je l'espère
pour vous un début de réponse quelle
émigration veut-on
quelle exigence demande-t-on aux
étrangers qui viennent sur notre sol et
quels moyens nous donnons-nous pour
appliquer la politique qui répond aux
deux premières questions
j'entends parfois encore une loi c'est
vrai que depuis 1986 une vingtaine de
lois ont été adoptées par le Parlement
français
je rappelle qu'une seule loi seulement a
été adoptée pendant le quinquennat du
président de la République celle de la
loi Colomb qui a permis notamment de
diminuer les délais de l'OFPRA quasiment
par deux puisque désormais c'est à peu
près en quatre mois que l'OFPRA
regardait demande d'asile je remarquerai
que sous les autres présidents notamment
la présidence du président Hollande en 5
ans trois lois ont été adoptées il est
pas tout à fait anormal que les
gouvernements et le Parlement
s'intéressent et légifèrent sur cette
question très importante de
l'immigration d'abord pour les
changements internationaux notamment
européens beaucoup de lois faisaient la
conséquence de directives qu'il fallait
évidemment traduire
législativement mais aussi parce que
l'immigration est protéiforme venant de
pays très différents pour des causes de
très différents et il n'est pas tout à
fait anormal que les parlements et que
les gouvernements s'adaptent à cette
situation par nature changeante
quelle est la structure de la
l'immigration en France elle connaît un
défaut je crois si on veut répondre à la
première question quelle migration
veut-on elle est trop familiale et pas
assez professionnelle elle n'est pas
assez qualifiée et elle est trop subie
et pas assez choisi avant toute chose je
veux ici dire même si ce n'est pas
l'objet de nos débats que la question
des migration ne pourrait pas se
résoudre en tant qu'adré pas réglé au
niveau européen qui nous paraît être je
crois le bon niveau pour répondre aux
questions que se posent tous les pays
européens je veux ici dire que cela
présence française de l'Union européenne
nous avons beaucoup avancé il faut
désormais que sous la présidence
suédoise et avant le Parlement européen
qui sera réélu au mois de juin prochain
nous terminions l'accord qui avait été
mené par la présidence française qui
repose sur quatre grands projets le
premier c'est évidemment la prévention
des départs on voit l'occasion d'en
reparler qui ne passe pas que par le
développement qui peut passer évidemment
par le développement mais qui passe
aussi par le départ au sens littéral du
terme et notamment la prise en mer et le
drame qui ont connu les reconnu
évidemment les migrants au large
l'Italie nous rappelle évidemment que
c'est drame ne sont des drames avant
tout pour les personnes qui quittent
leur pays dans des conditions absolument
affreuses c'est prévention de départ
doit se faire avec les pays et l'Europe
doit être unie pour porter le même
discours avec tous ces pays qui doivent
faire leur travail
d'intégration de population et de non
encouragements de l'immigration
irrégulière ce qui est parfois le cas le
deuxième sujet c'est évidemment une
politique commune de l'Union européenne
dans les visas réadmissions il ne peut
pas y avoir de visa octroyés si les
réadmissions ce qu'on appelle les
laisser passer consulaires la politique
de retour n'est pas au rendez-vous de
ces pays malheureusement lorsqu'un pays
comme la France par exemple prend des
décisions courageuses de restriction de
visa si d'autres pays européens
devraient pas d'autres pays européennes
d'autres pays européens donnent ces
visas et ainsi vous perdez à la fois
votre action de restriction à des visas
tout en ayant évidemment pas gagné sur
votre politique de réadmission puisque
la vie européenne fait qu’avisa octroyer
dans un pays de l'Union européenne
s'applique pour l'ensemble de l'Union
européenne il faut donc absolument que
l'Europe sorte de son égoïsme et adopte
une politique commune une diplomatie
commune en matière de visa rémission et
que avec les pays qui sont des pays de
départ s'il n'acceptent pas le retour
des personnes que nous voulons plus sur
notre sol européen il n'y ait pas dans
aucun des pays de politique de visa
donnée cette politique a été adoptée par
le Conseil européen il faut évidemment
qu'elle se traduise en termes législatif
en termes diplomatique évidemment le
troisième sujet c'est la protection de
nos frontières les étrangers qui
arrivent sur le sol européen ne sont pas
tous enregistrés nous ne connaissons pas
toujours l'exact
identité de leur état civil pour plein
de raisons évidemment nous ne
connaissons pas leur vie et notamment
leur âge qui évidemment pose des
problèmes de reconnaissance d'adultes ou
de mineurs que les sénateurs ici
connaissent bien et nous connaissons pas
souvent leur histoire et notamment leur
histoire du point de vue des services de
renseignements nous avons adopté deux
textes extrêmement importants pour la
vie de l'Union européenne et donc pour
la France le règlement screening c'est à
dire l'enregistrement porte de l'Europe
et le règlement Eurodac ces textes ont
été adoptés par le Conseil européen il
faut désormais que la Commission Libé du
Parlement européen et que le Parlement
européen les acceptes pour que nous
puissions en effet avoir enfin une
politique de frontière commune et
d'enregistrement commun et enfin
quatrième point qui n'a pas été adopté
par le Conseil européen mais qui
mériterait d'être largement poussé par
les chefs d'État c'est une politique
unique de l'asile puisque aujourd'hui
les conditions de d'octroi de l'asile
sont différents entre les pays et on
pourrait évoquer que ces différences
jouent évidemment sur l'ensemble de nos
politiques migratoires et encouragent
parfois à sa zone de personnes à venir
alors qu'il ne mérite pas cet asile qui
n'ont pas droit à cet asile et donc
utilisent l'asile à des fins détournée
d'immigration irrégulière chacun le sait
une fois qu'on a dit qu'une grande
partie des sujets étaient européens il
n'est pas classique de s'arrêter ici de
mon Parlement français et évidemment il
y a des dispositions que peut prendre un
pays dans le cadre des règles
européennes et de la Constitution telle
qu'elle est en vigueur puisqu'il s'agit
messieurs les sénateurs d'un projet de
loi ordinaire et qui m'appartient pas de
revoir la politique conventionnelle ou
constitutionnelle de notre pays à ma
modeste place je veux ici souligner les
quatre grands points d'intérêt du projet
de loi le premier est d'abord une
simplification générale du droit qui a
été validée par deux hautes autorités
monsieur le Président d'abord votre
rapport adopté à l'unanimité de la
commission qu'il a contribué à le
produire mais aussi par le Conseil des
tâches accords à ceux de constater que
le projet de loi du gouvernement a connu
sur cette question extrêmement complexe
cela simplification générale du droit
appliqué au contentieux des étrangers le
Conseil d'État a bien voulu donner un
quitus important au gouvernement toutes
les mesures que nous proposons sont donc
constitutionnelles a priori et nous en
félicitons parce que beaucoup
d'interrogations existaient et notamment
monsieur le président
dans les propositions que vous avez
formulées je retiendrai facilement 4
très rapide d'abord la réforme du
contentieux en tant que tel le passage
de 12 procédures à 4 procédures c'est la
division par 3 du nombre de procédures
que peuvent utiliser les étrangers avant
d'être expulsés du territoire national
je rappelle que 50 % du contentieux du
tribunal administratif c'est le droit
des étrangers 40% des cours appels
administratives l'autre droite
administratif est complètement bouchée
si j'ose dire par ce contentieux qui est
désormais long illisible et qui
détournent finalement l'efficacité de
l'État qu'est-ce qui se passe la plupart
du temps lorsque un préfet prend un
arrêté de reconduite à la frontière
enfin le fameux qtf désormais bien connu
je crois pour une partie de nos
compatriotes des recours sans cesse
peuvent être formulés détaillerai pas
ici les sujets je pense que vous
rapporter le feront sans doute dans les
discussions que nous aurons plus
amplement et nous pouvons attendre
parfois un an et demi deux ans avant
d'avoir une réponse définitive qui
valide la position de l'État elle est
souvent valider à 70% des cases qui est
quand même plutôt des bonnes décisions
si j'ose dire du point de vue d'autorité
et préfectoral mais entre temps depuis
deux ans que ces contentieux existent
l'étranger a pu soit trouver un travail
de façon illégale et parfois de façon
légale le ministre du Travail il
reviendra notre propre incurie
administrative ou de la part de
personnes employeur voyou il a pu se
marier avoir en tout cas des relations
juridiques on va dire sur le territoire
de la République avoir des enfants les
inscrire à l'école et donc au bout d'un
moment la vie privée est familiale fait
que le temps a joué contre la décision
originale de l'État et parce que nous
n'avons pas été vite parce que les
contentieux sont trop nombreux on en est
à des situations improbables depuis de
très nombreuses années où l'État a
finalement raison et peu expulsé les
personnes même lorsqu'elle a laissé
passer consulaire mais ne peut
finalement pas le faire puisque le temps
long a joué pour la vie privée et
familiale de cette même personne donc la
réforme du contentieux est vraiment le
nœud gordien pour être beaucoup plus
rapide pour réduire drastiquement les
délais et c'est évidemment un point très
important de ce de ce projet de
l'extension évidemment à la vidéo
audience est quelque chose extrêmement
important aussi et elle fait évidemment
contestation de la part d'un certain
nombre de personnes mais nous pensons
que le droit c'est beaucoup numérisé et
que ces vidéos audience nous permettront
également de traduire ces réductions
drastiques des délais dans la réalité la
proposition du juge unique à la CNDA qui
permet de d'être beaucoup plus efficace
dans la rapidité des décisions prises
par le juge de la Cour nationale de
droit d'asile si nous avons dans la
Colomb diminué à quatre mois quatre mois
et demi l'étude d'une demande d'asile
c'est désormais
moyenne 9 mois parfois un an et demi
peut-être même plus lorsque l'appel est
formé devant la CNDA et donc nous devons
absolument drastiquement réduire là
aussi c'est ces recours pour pouvoir non
pas juger sur le fond différemment il
s'agit pas ici de proposer des critères
différents pour l'asile constitutionnel
mais de pouvoir donner plus de moyens et
de meilleure organisation pour juger
plus rapidement pour savoir si quelqu'un
a le droit à l'asile en France dans ces
cas là il faut qu'il le sache très vite
afin de protéger sa famille notamment et
s'il n'a pas le droit de l'asile en
France il faut qu'il le sache très vite
afin que nous puissions nous en séparer
l'expulser le plus rapidement possible
afin de pas créer de droits nouveaux qui
permettrait d'avoir d'autres titres de
séjour sur le territoire national et
enfin une mesure que je sais contester
et qui ne paraît importante et
j'essaierai de pouvoir convaincre les
sénateurs sur ce point c'est la
territorialisation de la CNDA sont
excessive centralisation pose évidemment
aussi des problèmes de rapidité en même
temps que cette simplification générale
du droit ce qui ne relève pas du
législatif mais du réglementaire je veux
ici présenter devant le Sénat la réforme
complète du réseau de nos préfectures de
leur façon de fonctionner qui concentre
leurs moyens beaucoup trop sur le suivi
des titres de séjour déjà déposés et qui
embête énormément les étrangers qui
souvent ne posent strictement aucun
problème à la République deviennent
parfois irréguliers du fait de notre
propre incurie administrative et donc
les mettant assis dans des dispositions
extrêmement vis-à-vis de leur employeur
vis-à-vis de leur famille et vis-à-vis
évidemment du droit tout court mais
aussi en pêche sans doute de voir soit
les grosses efforts d'intégration que
l'État doit accompagner avec les moyens
que nous allons lui octroyer mais aussi
mieux vérifier les dossier des primo
arrivants puisque aujourd'hui si je
devais résumer nous passons beaucoup de
temps à demander des documents
administratifs il y a des gens qui
depuis très nombreuses années parfois
des je pense aux Chibani qui ont 75 80
85 90 ans à qui on demande encore de
venir en préfecture déposer un dossier
que ça fait 60 ans qui sont sur le
territoire national n'ont parfois été
décorés par d'autres pays sur les
courageux pendant pendant nos guerres et
ne pas essayer de temps pour vérifier le
casier judiciaire ou la bonne
intégration la personne qui vient
d'arriver sur le territoire national
j'aurai l'occasion de détailler cette
réforme profonde du fonctionnement de
nos préfectures et des par les moyens
octroyés d'ailleurs par le projet de loi
de finances que vous avez bien voulu
adopter ça permettra monsieur le
Président je sais que vous y êtes
attaché d'adopter si le Sénat le
souhaite fameuse mesure guide du 360
degrés puisque ça nous permettra
évidemment avec cette révolution des
préfectures de faire que quand quelqu'un
déposera une demande ce sera à l'état de
vérifier l'intégralité des titres
auxquels il a droit de dire un nom
définitif pour tous les titres bien sûr
et de pas avoir cette répétition de
dossiers plus des mesures de
simplification dans le droit du travail
que présentera le ministre du soft le
deuxième point après la simplification
drastique du droit des étrangers c'est
le renforcement considérable des
exigences d'intégration que demande que
demandons aux étrangers le gouvernement
dans de façon tout à fait réglementaire
depuis que je suis ministre de
l'Intérieur a considérablement augmenté
les exigences pour devenir français pour
la naturalisation d'ailleurs je constate
qu'il y a à peu près 30% de
naturalisation donnée en moins en 5 ans
notre pays dans ce paradoxe un peu
particulier où il y a plus étrangers sur
le sol national d'où le texte que nous
vous proposons est moins de gens qui
deviennent français pourquoi parce que
entretien d'assimilation exigences du
niveau linguistique le passage avec un
entretien parfois plusieurs entretiens
devant les agents de préfecture fait que
moins de gens deviennent français parce
que les exigences sont beaucoup plus
fortes que ce n'était encore 5 ou 10 ans
il n'y a pas de d'articles sur le code
nationalité dans le projet que nous
présentons il s'agit intégralement du
droit des étrangers et non pas de ceux
qui peuvent devenir français mais nous
souhaitons appliquer puisque là c'est
législatif à ceux qui ont des titres des
séjours sur le territoire national qui
pourrait en avoir les mêmes exigences ou
quasiment les exigences par Robotis que
nous le demandons à ceux qui vont
devenir français ça passe par trois
grands sujets le premier c'est
évidemment la langue
l'une des révolutions de ce projet de
loi c'est de passer d'une obligation de
moyen une obligation de résultat pour
toute personne qui aura à titre de
séjour ou qui a déjà un titre de séjour
puisque ça concerne évidemment aussi le
stock pardon de ce mauvais mot des
étrangers qui sont sur notre sol
national c'est-à-dire à peu près 300000
titres par an
pour toute personne qui donc un titre de
séjour pourrait avoir un titre de séjour
long sur le territoire national donc pas
visa de court séjour pour les gens qui
viendraient faire passer quelques jours
de vacances chacun leur a compris l'idée
de ce projet de loi c'est de
conditionner l'octroi de ce titre de
séjour à un critère supplémentaire qui
est la réussite d'un examen de français
le ministre du Travail dira sans doute
que déjà va entre 20 et 25% de personnes
qui sont réguliers sur le territoire
national comprennent extrêmement mal le
français ce qui évidemment empêche
beaucoup le travail et beaucoup
d'intégration mais cette exigence
désormais de l'examen de réussite de
français c'est évidemment quelque chose
qui contribuera très largement à
répondre à la première question quelle
migration voulons-nous l'immigration qui
parle et qui comprennent notre langue
c'est évidemment une révolution aussi
pour les services des des préfectures la
deuxième exigence d'intégration c'est
une disposition qui est inspirée
directement de la loi dite séparatisme
que la majorité sénatoriale a également
voté je n'en aussi qui confine à
effectivement demander à ce que les
étrangers qui sont sur des titres de ces
jours longs là aussi il s'agit pas de
regarder les gens qui ont un visa
touristique bien évidemment mais titre
de séjour long un engagement de respect
des valeurs de la République son emblème
l'hymne national le devis de la
République le caractère laïque de la
République la liberté religieuse et bien
sûr l'orientation sexuelle cette
personne qui viendra sur notre sol devra
signer son engagement assez respecté ses
principes de la République qu'est-ce que
cela entraînerait s'il ne les signes pas
il n'aurait pas de ces jours on peut
imaginer que beaucoup d'entre le signe
quand même ça entraînerait le fait que
par exemple aujourd'hui une mise à
l'intérieur ne peut pas retirer son
titre de séjour un homme qui refuse
d'être soigné par une femme chez un
médecin et demain ce sera le cas si la
disposition évidemment est adoptée par
le Parlement il y a la poursuite pénale
ça c'était la loi dite séparatisme il y
a le retrait administratif du titre de
séjour ça c'est le texte que je propose
aujourd'hui
et puis il y a le troisième point sur
l'intégration qui est intéressant par le
travail mais je laisserai le ministre du
Travail évidemment développé ce sujet je
voudrais dire que pour mettre être au
rendez-vous des exigences d'intégration
que nous demandons vous avez voté une
enveloppe extrêmement importante dans la
loi de modernisation du ministère de
l'intérieur parce que vous avez augmenté
de 25 % les crédits de l'intégration
c'est la plus grande hausse des crises
d'intégration qui a connu la République
106 millions d'euros pour les trois
prochaines années nous pensons que c'est
suffisant pour être au rendez-vous de
ces exigences c'est évidemment
extrêmement important de le souligner
devant le Parlement après la
simplification drastique du contentieux
après les exigences qui passent
notamment par la langue et par les
respects dans la République des
étrangers je veux souligner le troisième
point très important de ce projet de loi
c'est l'expulsion des étrangers menacent
l'ordre public pour faire très simple
c'est la fin de la fin de la double
peine où le rétablissement d'une
certaine double peine que vous le
souhaitez et la lutte contre les
filières d'immigration irrégulière
si je commence par la filière
d'immigrations régulières donc qu'est-ce
qu'on essaie de faire dans ce projet de
loi c'est donner des armes désormais au
préfet au ministère de l'Intérieur il y
a la justice de pouvoir lutter contre le
continuum pour utiliser un mot que
chacun connaît ici de l'immigration
irrégulière organisée malheureusement
nous constatons que
[Musique]
utilisant la misère des personnes des
femmes d'enfants de personnes
étrangers dans toutes de toute nature
les passeurs sont de véritables
criminels et sont responsables à la fois
évidemment la situation d'immigration
régulière que nous connaissons mais
aussi des drames qu'on a connu à caler
comme au large de l'Italie encore
extrêmement récemment je l'ai dit
d'abord c'est un renforcement
extrêmement fort de sanctions contre les
patrons les employeurs voyous qui
embauchent les personnes irrégulières je
laisserai le ministre du Travail
l'évoquer c'est ensuite notre propre
accurerie administrative qui est visée
avec la fin notamment du statut
d'auto-entrepreneur que l'on peut créer
même lorsqu'on a pas de papier en règle
et qui crée je crois que chacun le const
des trappes nous-mêmes à emploi et donc
à régularisation ou à Nini ni
régularisable ni expulsable je laisserai
également le ministre du Travail en
parler ensuite c'est une peine de prison
extrêmement forte passant ainsi de
délits Hakim le crime de passeur de 20
ans de prison pour ceux qui se rendent
coupables de passage d'immigrés
clandestins si évidemment cela entraîne
la mort de ces personnes et de 15 ans si
ça s'entraîne pas la mort c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui le minimum des
condamnations des passeurs que nous
retrouvons et pour lequel la
préjudiciaire et des polices
internationales grâce à Europole font de
magnifiques affaires ne sont pas la
hauteur du crime que nous constatons
puisque c'est entre 1 et 7 ans selon les
jugements des tribus d'eau le passage
dans un crime dans le code pénal on le
doit au garder ça je le remercie et je
pense que ce serait une mesure
extrêmement attendue par les polices
judiciaires et par la police aux
frontières et c'est également lutter
contre les marchands de sommeil une
disposition est extrêmement importante
dans ce projet de loi j'en ai été fait
l'écho médiatiquement aujourd'hui n'est
pas reconnu comme une personne
vulnérable l'étranger en situation
irrégulière qui est embauché et pardon à
un bail un faux évidemment en tout cas
pas au sens légal du terme chez un
marchand de chez un marchand de sommeil
nous prévoyons ici évidemment la
pénalisation la délictualisation du
marchand de sommeil qui donne ses
logements et qui parfois pourrissent nos
communes à ces personnes extrêmement
vulnérables étrangère devient donc une
personne vulnérable qui nous permet de
lutter contre ceux qui souvent
d'ailleurs dans les enquêtes de police
sont montrées comme étant ceux qui
tiennent parfois l'emploi qui emploient
ces personnes de manière irrégulière
mais aussi le logement créant ainsi
d'énormes réseaux d'immigration
irrégulière qui au fil du temps
deviennent malheureusement des personnes
qu'on ne peut plus expulser tant ils
peuvent montrer qu'ils ont eu leur vie
privée et familiale dans notre pays
deuxième point après le contenu après le
continuum il y a les frontières
[Musique]
relever
de ces de ces appareils et puis
troisième sujet nous avons négocié
précédemment dans les Conseils européens
un sujet très important qui s'appelle
Ethias c'est une donc traduction
législative de décision européenne pour
faire très vite nous allons mettre en
place l'entrée sortie Schengen dans
notre sur notre continent ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que désormais ce qui
n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui tout
citoyen de l'espace Schengen et tout
étranger qui rentre dans l'espace
Schengen aura une fiche biométrique à
l'ensemble des frontières aéroportuaires
portuaires frontières tout court dans
l'Europe ce qui nous permettra de suivre
l'intégralité des personnes qui sont de
votre sol ça fait écho à ce que je
disais en introduction de pouvoir
regarder bien sûr leur identité
connaître leur âge sans aucune
contestation possible grâce à leur
empreinte ne pas les confondre avec des
faux documents et de pouvoir évidemment
avoir une politique européenne de
contrôle et donc une fois qu'on a fait
l'entrée sortie Schengen 6 mois après
nous pouvons faire Ethias c'est quoi
Ethias c'est le fait que toutes les
polices et gendarmerie européenne
pourront sur leur contrôle de téléphone
Neo vous savez ce que ce qu'on les
policiers gendarmes quand vous les voyez
dans la rue pour en faire des
vérifications identité de Schengen c'est
à dire que personne ne pourra plus
tricher sur son identité à partir du
moment où nous aurons mis en place ce
système Ethias il nous faut une
disposition législative pour le mettre
en place évidemment Ethias pour nous est
important non seulement pour lutter
contre l'immigration irrégulière pour
pouvoir mieux expulser les personnes qui
ne sont pas régulières mais aussi dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme dans la
perspective des Jeux olympiques de Paris
enfin je terminerai sur la fin de la fin
de la double peine les dispositions de
l'article 9 et l'article 10 avec une
difficulté pour l'article 10 on y
reviendra peut-être puisque quand c'est
l'État a décidé de le disjoindre mais
nous avons décidé de le remettre dans le
texte pour que nous ayons ce débat ici
devant le Sénat c'est de dire qu'il ne
peut plus y avoir de protection pour les
personnes qui commettent des crimes
des délits extrêmement graves sur le sol
de la République donc ce qui relève de
10 ans de prison ou 5 ans en récidive
j'ai bien ce qui relève et pas ce qui
est condamné on aura sans doute un long
débat sur ce sujet aujourd'hui
8 dispositions empêchent à l'intérieur
d'expulser ces personnes chacun se
rappelle que c'est dans les années 2000
que la fin la double peine a été mis en
place et qui n'a été copié par aucun
pays européen et qui n'est ni
conventionnel ni constitutionnel
d'ailleurs le Conseil d'État
l'ajustement relevé si vous étiez marié
avec un français ou une français si vous
aviez des enfants en France bref si vous
étiez arrivé en France avant l'âge de 13
ans et vous commettiez les actes après
l'âge de 18 ans il y avait un certain
nombre de protection qui était prévu par
la loi le miniso intérieur quand même
vous auriez commis des crimes ignobles
ne pouvait pas vous expulser parce que
la vie privée est familiale était ainsi
sauvegardée si j'ose dire à binicio nous
proposons que nous fassions tomber
l'intégralité de ces protections
subsidiaires de ces protections d'ordre
public et désormais nous ne regardions
pas la situation de la personne selon sa
vie privée familiale mais qu'en gagnant
le crime que la Comic nous puissions
expulser ainsi ces personnes bien sûr
elle pourra toujours avoir recours
devant le juge qui pourra considérer que
la décision de l'administrative est
exagérée mais je constate que on fait
souvent dire au juge des choses qui ne
dit pas vous savez que ces dispositions
n'est pas valable pour les actes
qualifient de terrorisme de séparatiste
et le Conseil d'État parfois on l'a vu
dans l'affaire ecuissen donne raison au
ministère de l'Intérieur et la vie
privée familiale alors que cette
personne par exemple avait eu quatre
enfants nés en France qui s'étaient
mariés en France que ça faisait que
lui-même était né en France a quand même
considérer évidemment que l'État avait
raison de se défendre contre ce sinistre
personnage et donc à autoriser son
expulsion la fin de la fin de la double
peine c'est évidemment une disposition
extrêmement forte pour lutter contre les
étrangers auteurs d'actes de vacances
extrêmement grave on pense au crime on
pense bien évidemment aux attentes aux
policiers et aux gendarmes aux atteintes
aux élus aux conjugales et au trafic de
drogue demain ces personnes malgré leur
statut personnel ne pourront pas
revendiquer la protection de la vie
privée et familiale devant le ministère
de l'Intérieur pour connaître leur
expulsion ce qui sera une bonne chose
voilà monsieur le Président en quelques
mots la présentation très succinct trop
succinct des articles qui relèvent
directement de la compétence merci
Monsieur de la parole tout de suite
monsieur travaille monsieur Duchamp
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Miss chergérald madame et monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs à mon tour en quelques mots de
revenir sur les dispositions du projet
de loi que nous vous présentons avec
Gérald Darmanin pour ce qui concerne le
travail et en particulier l'intégration
par le travail et par la langue les
dispositions nous vous présentons
s'appuient en réalité sur un constat et
une conviction le constat est que le
marché du travail tel que nous le
connaissons en France ne propose pas une
situation professionnelle satisfaisante
aux étrangers qui sont présents sur
notre territoire les chiffres le
montrent l'illustre depuis maintenant
longtemps
quel que soit le contexte économique en
cas de récession comme en cas de
croissance comme en cas de reprise le
taux de chômage des personnes nées à
l'étranger et en moyenne presque deux
fois supérieure au taux de chômage des
personnes nées en France même dans une
période de création d'emplois
importantes comme celle que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et de tension de
recrutement lorsque le taux de chômage
est à 7,2 % pour le taux de chômage
général et la population générale il est
à 13% pour les personnes qui sont nées à
l'étranger donc présentes comme immigré
sur notre territoire c'est d'autant plus
frappant que nous avons un système qui
est d'une part ne permet pas
d'accompagner suffisamment vers l'emploi
les étrangers en situation régulière sur
notre territoire et qui dans le même
temps maintient dans les régularités
maintient dans l'illégalité des hommes
et des femmes qui depuis longtemps sont
présents sur le territoire et
travaillent très souvent de manière
régulière mais j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir cela aboutit à des situations
souvent inextricables avec des
entreprises qui comptent sur un certain
nombre de salariés alors que leur
présence sur le territoire était
régulière
bien même leur emploi et lui déclarait
et tout à fait régulier et des
situations qui lorsque la justice en est
saisie amène à sa situation inextricable
présentée par le ministre de l'intérieur
ou l'expulsion et prononcée mais en
réalité elle n'est pas possible pour des
éléments relatifs à la vie privée
familiale et un ancienneté de
l'installation sur le territoire donc
nous pensons que les principes de
justice et les principes d'efficacité
demandent et comment si je puis dire
d'apporter une réponse à cette
difficulté la conviction après le
constat c'est que l'intégration et la
bonne intégration la meilleure
intégration passe à la fois par le
travail et par la longue par le travail
parce que c'est évidemment un facteur
d'autonomie d'émancipation et d'accès à
la capacité à des individus de
construire et finalement de vivre sur le
territoire de la manière la plus
autonome possible et la langue pour
cette capacité évidemment à s'intégrer à
parler à partager et à communiquer avec
toutes celles et ceux qui nous entourent
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitons avec ce texte proposer des
mesures qui permettent d'abord de
favoriser l'intégration par le travail
de favoriser l'apprentissage de la
langue et d'en faire une des
motivations en tout cas un
obligation pour réussir c'est parcours
d'intégration c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle nous voulons que celles et ceux
qui se prêtent délibérément au
recrutement de personnes en situation
irrégulière puisse être plus durement
plus durement sanctionné pour ce qui
concerne l'intégration par le travail
nous proposons donc de créer un nouveau
type de séjour temporaire relatif aux
métiers en tension avec une volonté qui
est que ce type de séjour tel que prévu
à l'article 3 puis s'adresser à des
salariés des secteurs les plus
intensions en termes d'emploi pour
faciliter l'intégration de ces
travailleurs étrangers qui contribue
déjà le plus activement à soulager les
tensions de recrutement et qui
travaillent sur notre territoire il ne
s'agit pas d'un titre de séjour pensé
pour susciter la venue sur le territoire
d'étrangers non communautaire et
j'insiste d'ailleurs sur le caractère
non communautaire puisque dès lors qu'on
parle d’étranger communautaire la
liberté de circulation fait qu'ils ne
sont pas concernés par les dispositions
que vous présentons il s'agit d'un titre
qui permet de régulariser la situation
d'hommes et de femmes qui sont présents
sur notre territoire depuis longtemps et
qui travaillent très souvent d'ailleurs
d'hommes et de femmes qui travaillent
parce que au moment où ils ont signé un
contrat de travail ils étaient en
situation régulière et que leur titre de
séjour n'a pas été renouvelés pour une
raison pour une autre et nous traduisons
cette intention de régulariser
uniquement des personnes sur notre
territoire qui travaille et qui d'une
certaine manière disent leur volonté
d'intégration participe à leur
intégration par le travail en précisant
dans le projet de loi que nous vous
présentons que cette éligibilité à ce
nouveau type de séjour sera conditionné
par une présence sur le territoire
depuis au moins trois ans et le fait
d'avoir travaillé au moins 8 mois au
cours des 24 derniers mois et donc nous
sommes véritablement dans une logique de
critères pour faire en sorte que ces
travailleurs ne restent pas sans droit
ni au séjour ni au travail et puisse
ainsi voir leur situation régularisée
afin que là aussi la sécurité juridique
temporeux que pour leur employeur pour
définir les secteurs en tension nous
souhaitons nous appuyer sur la liste des
métiers en tension qui existent déjà qui
répertorie dans l'état du droit les
métiers où il est possible de recruter
de la main d'oeuvre étrangère non
communautaire sans eau sans opposabilité
de l'administration aujourd'hui
lorsqu'on employeur souhaite recruter un
salarié non étranger non communautaire
il est tenu de demander préalablement à
la signature du contrat de travail une
autorisation administrative de signer ce
contrat de travail qui conditionne
d'ailleurs l'accès à un visa ou
l'autorisation d'entrer sur le
territoire la liste des métiers en
tension telle qu'elle existe telle
qu'elle a été réactualisée il est encore
quelques années permet aux employeurs
qui recrutent des étrangers non
communautaires de s'affranchir de cette
autorisation administrative dès lors
qu'il recrute sur un poste répertorié
comme étant particulièrement attention
nous souhaitons donc utiliser cette
liste pour permettre d'intégrer plus
rapidement des travailleurs étrangers
déjà sur le territoire et non pas en
recrutement et qui exerce donc dans ces
métiers les plus intensions cette liste
doit être révisée de nombreuses
organisations professionnelles nous ont
dit notamment dans le secteur de la
restauration dans le secteur de
l'entretien des bâtiments et des locaux
l'inadéquation entre la liste et la
situation du marché du travail tel que
nous la connaissons aujourd'hui il y a
par exemple dans les secteurs de la
restauration le métier de comic-cuisine
qui n'apparaît pas dans la liste comme
étant en tension de la même manière que
les agents de l'entretien des bâtiments
hommes et femmes de ménage
n'apparaissent pas dans la liste des
métiers en tension alors que nous savons
que la part des étrangers non
communautaires a exercé dans ces métiers
particulièrement importante cette liste
doit faire donc l'objet d'une révision
cette révision est encadrée par un
certain nombre de critères notamment
statistiques et prend une dimension
régionale puisque la liste est souvent
présentée comme une liste nationale et
en réalité elle connaît des déclinaisons
régionales pour être la plus adaptée
possible aux besoins de l'économie à
l'échelle de territoire régionaux qui
d'après la jurisprudence sont
suffisamment larges pour éviter de créer
des phénomènes de discrimination si des
territoires plus étroits plus réduits
étaient retenus
cette procédure que nous voulons créer
vient en réalité après une première
expérience que nous connaissons celle de
la circulaire dites valse qui prévoit
des admissions exceptionnelles au séjour
admission exceptionnelle au séjour qui
pour une part importante sont des
admissions motivées par des motifs
familiaux sociaux privés et pour une
part moins importante et même
minoritaire pour des motifs économiques
bonhomme si vous me permettez cette
expression ce sont à peu près 7000
admissions exceptionnelles au séjour qui
sont prononcés au titre de la circulaire
Valls pour des motifs professionnels ou
économiques et nous pensons même s'il
est toujours difficile de prévoir le
rythme auquel des régularisations de
situations déjà existantes pourraient
intervenir que certainement un chiffre
autour duquel nous pourrions aboutir
dans le cadre de la mise en oeuvre de
cet article 3 cette circulaire valse
présente deux difficultés d'abord une
application hétérogène sur le territoire
puisque renvoyer à une forme de pouvoir
discrétionnaire des autorités
préfectorales et une autre difficulté
qui implique que l'employeur
se déclare et accompagne la
régularisation il y a deux limites qui
sont créées par cette obligation de
participation de l'employeur la première
et qu'il existe légitimement des
employeurs qui craignent cette
exposition puisqu'ils doivent dire à un
moment que tel ou tel de leur salarié
est en situation irrégulière sur le
territoire et ce n'est pas forcément une
démarche facile il y a une autre limite
qui heureusement plus minoritaire mais
qui est beaucoup plus grave qui consiste
à ce que des employeurs le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui est qualifie tout à
l'heure à raison l'employeur voyou
trouve tout à fait confortable et tout à
fait positif pour eux de pouvoir
s'appuyer sur des salariés en situation
irrégulière parce que ça crée un rapport
de dépendance et évidemment ça change le
lien du contrat tel que défini par le
contrat de travail nous souhaitons donc
avec ce nouveau titre les étrangers en
situation irrégulière mais exerçant une
activité depuis plusieurs mois et étant
présent sur le territoire depuis
plusieurs années activité régulière
puisse solliciter eux-mêmes leur
régularisation
évidemment si nous nous contentions de
créer un titre de un an renouvelable au
même condition nous ne ferions que
repousser le problème d'une certaine
manière et prévoyons que les étrangers
concernés puissent par exemple si ils
sont signataires d'un CDI à terme
demandés l'accès à une carte de séjour
plus réelle mais dans ce cas-là cet
accès à une carte de séjour plus réelle
serait soumis au même critères que ceux
exposés par le ministre de l'Intérieur
notamment en matière de maîtrise de la
langue ou d'engagement sur les valeurs
républicaines je sais que cette
disposition suicide des interrogations
elle suscite des attentes notamment dans
les secteurs économiques les plus
concernés les fédérations
professionnelles les plus concernées
mais comme elle suit des interrogations
il nous paraît important à la fois dans
des battre mais aussi de prévoir que le
Parlement puisse après une première
période de mise en oeuvre de cette
réforme
évaluer son effet et décider ou non de
sa conduction c'est la raison pour
laquelle le texte ne vous que nous vous
présentons prévoit une clause de
revoyure au 31 décembre 2026 pour que
sur la base de cette évaluation le
Parlement puisse décider si cette
nouveauté de séjour doit être pérennisée
ou non lorsqu'on souhaite finalement
sécuriser la présence de travailleurs
sur le territoire cela implique un
corollaire qui est d'empêcher que de
telles situations puissent se reproduire
et en particulier le situation sont tout
à fait délibérées je pense aux
employeurs qui délibérément ont recours
à des personnes en situation irrégulière
à la fois pour des activités
professionnelles régulières et parfois
pour des activités professionnelles non
régulières lorsqu'il y a des activités
non professionnel non régulière et
exercées par des situations en Suède des
personnes en situation irrégulière ça
mérite évidemment les sanctions les plus
fortes et c'est la raison pour laquelle
maintenant bien évidemment les sanctions
pénales telles qu'elles sont prévues et
qui viennent sanctionner les situations
les plus graves et les délaiss les plus
graves nous souhaitons cependant que les
employeurs qui délibérément recrutent
des personnes en situation irrégulière
même si c'est pour exercer une activité
régulière puis cette sanctionner plus
rapidement les procédures pénales que
j'ai évoquées sont souvent une sortie de
sanction lourde mais elles sont longues
et donc nous souhaitons pouvoir créer
une amende administrative à la main des
autorités administratives et donc
préfectorales pour sanctionner à hauteur
de 4000 euros par salarié étrangers
employés légalement les employeurs qui
délibérément on recourt à de la main
d'oeuvre en situation irrégulière
l'avantage d'une sanction administrative
c'est sa rapidité et la possibilité
d'infliger une sanction dans un moment
suffisamment rapproché du moment où
l'infraction est constatée alors que les
sanctions pénales qui sont plus lourdes
bien évidemment avec beaucoup plus de
temps nous souhaitons aussi le ministre
de l'Intérieur a dit empêcher la
création en tout cas l'apparition de
situation dans lesquelles des personnes
en situation irrégulière sur le
territoire crée eux-mêmes une activité
économique une activité professionnelle
de manière régulière je pense à la
création d'entreprises individuelle
l'accès aux statut d'entreprise
individuelle comme l'accès aux statut
d'auto-entrepreneur aujourd'hui nous
devons renforcer les conditions pour
accéder à ce statut d'entreprise
individuelle ou d'auto-entrepreneurs et
nous prévoyons dans l'article 5 de
conditionner cet accès aux personnes en
situation régulière sur le territoire et
donc d'obliger la présentation d'un
titre de séjour régulé sur le territoire
pour pouvoir ainsi créer une entreprise
individuelle ou accéder au statut
d'auto-entrepreneur aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas le cas ça n'est pas suffisamment
encadré et c'est ainsi que très
régulièrement les plateformes puisque
nous renvoyons souvent au travail de
plateforme en la matière son contrainte
de déconnecter un certain nombre de
profils dès lors qu'elle constate que
celui ou celle qui est derrière le
profil d'auto-entrepreneur est en
réalité en situation irrégulière il y a
un certain nombre d'autres mesures que
nous vous proposons de prendre pour
faciliter l'intégration par le travail
et lever un certain nombre de
contraintes je pense notamment à
l'article 4 qui a comme objectif de
faciliter l'accès au travail d'un
certain nombre d'une partie des
demandeurs d'asile je m'explique en un
mot lorsque vous êtes demandeur d'asile
vous n'avez pas le droit d'exercer une
activité professionnelle sauf au bout de
six mois ou après six mois passés sur le
territoire si la demande d'asile n'a pas
été construite de manière définitive
vous pouvez solliciter une dérogation et
obtenir le droit de travailler et
ensuite si vous êtes reconnu et si votre
demande d'asile aboutit vous avez
évidemment le droit au travail nous
proposons que chaque année un arrêté du
ministre de l'Intérieur puisse
déterminer la liste des pays pour
lesquels les taux d'admission sont les
plus élevés et permettent pour ces seuls
pays la possibilité de travailler pour
les demandeurs d'asile le fait de
renvoyer cette définition de liste à un
arrêté elle mérite de la souplesse tout
à l'heure le ministre de l'Intérieur l'a
dit la liste des pays pour lesquels les
taux d'acceptation des demandes d'asile
sur les plus élevés est une liste qui
varie extrêmement vite au gré des
évolutions géopolitiques et donc il faut
pouvoir modifier cette liste aussi
rapidement que varie les taux
d'admission de manière à être efficace
et ne pas créer un flux que nous ne
serions maîtrisé
la deuxième chose que nous voulons faire
en termes de levée de contraintes ne
concerne pas des personnes présentes sur
le territoire mais des personnes qui
aujourd'hui souhaitent venir travailler
en France dans le cadre de ce que nous
appelons le passeport talent nous
souhaitons modifier le passeport talent
qui existe aujourd'hui qui est organisé
en 11 catégories en regroupant les
catégories pour lui donner plus de
lisibilité parler de cartes de séjour
talons et permettre la venue sur le
territoire de personnes extrêmement
compétentes formées avec des projets
d'investissement et qui répondent à des
besoins de notre économie et des besoins
en termes d'attractivité et nous
souhaitons par ailleurs créer une carte
spécifique pour les talents dans le
domaine des professions médicales
notamment les médecins les pharmaciens
les chirurgiens dentistes avec des
procédures d'admission particulière des
délais particuliers mais aussi bien
évidemment la vérification de toutes les
équivalences pour permettre de garantir
la qualité des soins je termine par un
point sur la question de l'intégration
par l'apprentissage de la langue nous
grandi et le ministre de l'Intérieur a
dit aussi nous souhaitons relever les
niveaux d'exigence en termes
linguistique pour obtenir une carte de
séjour plus réelle un instant de ce qui
existe pour obtenir une carte de
résidence c'est une nouvelle exigence
qui est fixée à l'article 1 de même
qu'il est prévu à l'article 2 que nous
permettions que nous puissions permettre
aux travailleurs étrangers qui demandent
la possibilité d'obtenir une carte de
séjour plus réelle de se former aux
Français c'est la raison pour laquelle
en plus des dispositions d'insertion
d'intégration de formation français tels
que prévu par la loopnie et qui ont été
évoqués dans le propos de Gérald
Darmanin nous prévoyons que cet article
2 autorise le gouvernement à prendre un
décret après une constatation
interprofessionnelle pour dire quel
nombre d'heures de formation français
pour être effectué sur le temps de
travail en réalité ce à quoi nous
voulons apporter une réponse c'est la
situation d'hommes et de femmes qui
travaillent souvent dans des secteurs en
tension et avec des rythmes des horaires
parfois compliqué dans le domaine de
restauration dans le domaine de
l'entretien et pour qui il est
extrêmement compliqué de cumuler sur la
même journée sur la même semaine à la
fois leur activité professionnelle avec
le fait d'assister au cours nécessaire
de français pour obtenir le niveau
demandé désormais qui sera demandé
désormais pour obtenir une carte de
séjour plus réelle et donc prévoyons
qu'il puisse ainsi se voir libérer du
temps pour participer à ces formations
et ainsi satisfaire à cette nouvelle
obligation et cette nouvelle exigence
que nous donnons voilà monsieur le
Président les différents points qui
concernent l'intégration par le travail
et par la langue que contient ce projet
de loi
merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
Monsieur les ministres je vais
maintenant donner la parole à nos
rapporteurs puis ensuite d'autres
collègues sont déjà inscrits pour des
prises de parole madame Jorda merci
monsieur le Président nous allons
peut-être poser nos questions
en une seule fois si je puis dire je
suis bonne Carrère et moi-même ce qui
permettra à Monsieur et ministre de nous
répondre première question qui a trait
aux articles 1 et 2 donc qui s'adresse à
vous monsieur dussof sur le niveau de
langue dont vous indiquez que vous avez
rehaussé le niveau d'exigence il faut
dire qu'il n'y en avait pas pour
l'instant si ce n'est le fait d'assister
à la formation aujourd'hui vous prévoyez
qu'un niveau de langue doit être atteint
pour pouvoir se voir délivrer une carte
de séjour pluriannuelle mais vous
n'indiquez jamais dans la loi quel est
le niveau de langue alors je sais que il
peut nous être répondu que c'est
réglementaire nous nous estimons que ces
législatif et c'est toujours assez
difficile mais c'est souvent le cas dans
ce texte de prendre une décision sans
savoir véritablement
la demande qui va être qui va être
formulée donc pouvez-vous nous dire quel
est le niveau de langue qui est
envisagée dans le cas de l'étude
d'impact vous aviez indiqué que il était
déjà envisagé de rehausser le niveau de
langue pour l'acquisition de la
nationalité française il n'en a rien été
pour l'instant quand est-il exactement
de ce projet donc quel va être le niveau
de langue qui va être exigé
par ailleurs vous l'avez indiqué à
l'instant dans l'article 2 les
employeurs sont mis à contribution pour
pouvoir permettre à l'étranger qui
travaille d'acquérir ce niveau de langue
par des mesures de contraintes qui sont
beaucoup plus fortes que dans la
formation professionnelle habituelle que
répondez-vous à ceux qui disent que ça
n'est pas aux employeurs de faire les
frais en quelque sorte de la politique
migratoire de la France
merci
Philippe bonnecareire
votre question était posée du Sud alors
je vais aller vers monsieur Darmanin
pour faire et puis après je reviendrai
monsieur du sol bien sûr sur avec
l'article 3 il sans doute une question
monsieur Darmanin sur la réforme du
contentieux des étrangers
vous avez avec habilité
difficultés
traditionnel fait référence au travail
Stal et au rapport de notre Président
Monsieur buffet
pourtant la proposition
législatives que vous nous faites
sur ce sujet ne correspond pas à la
proposition
stable buffet la proposition stade
buffet c'était
un critère d'urgence on est sur une
procédure d'urgence cher tribunal
administratif du juge très rapidement
on est sur une procédure normale tu as
un délai plus classique pour apprécier
pour un peintre mis en tension
ce n'est pas exactement ce que vous avez
souhaité faire j'ai toujours une
procédure normale j'ai toujours deux
procédures d'urgence une procédure que
j'appellerai avec assignation résidence
et l'autre placement ancra vous avez des
niveaux de de délai qui sont un petit
peu différents mais je ne fais pas je
vais pas rentrer dans trop de détails et
vous créez une nouvelle procédure qui
manifestement dans votre esprit à
vocation être à la procédure majoritaire
ou
vous dites à un étranger mon cher
Monsieur ou ma chère Madame
je
vous demande de quitter le territoire
immédiatement
il n'y a pas de délai et donc dans ce
cadre vous demandez au Tribunal
Administratif de juger dans le cadre
d'un délit rapide mais vous n'avez pris
ni mesure des signations résidence ni
mesure de placement serra ce qui nous
laisse à penser que vous allez mettre en
tension les tribunaux administratifs
pour des situations qui ont en réalité
peu de chances de conduire à une Éloi à
un éloignement ou un éloignement rapide
puisque ce sont par définition des
situations où je n'ai ni assignation
résidence ni éloignement donc ma
question est la suivante pourquoi
n'avez-vous pas purement et simplement
suivi les préconisations stables buffet
ou buffet Stal et pourquoi vous créez
cette procédure intermédiaire dont on
voit bien l'intérêt dans votre esprit
d'accélérer la procédure mais vous axé
de vous demander au tribunal
administratif d'aller vite pour régler
des situations dans tous les pensées
qu'elles ne feront pas l'objet d'un
éloignement rapide il nous semble y
avoir une contradiction vous comprenez à
travers mes propos que nous avons un
faible pour la proposition stale buffet
mais nous en écoutant volontiers votre
argumentation pour ne pas l'avoir suivi
mais encore une question même Jourda
puis par le ministre
et à Monsieur bonne Carrère non on
prenait au global et puis on fera une
réponse on va si vous voulez bien on va
poser peut-être parce qu'après les
questions des rapporteurs et ensuite
voilà nous nous dirons pour un moment
une question qui s'adresse sans doute à
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur vous
avez indiqué tout à l'heure que dans les
articles et 10 pour les résumer sans
entrer dans le détail technique il
s'agissait de lever les protections qui
aujourd'hui s'appliquait à des étrangers
qui ont commis des faits qui troublent
l'ordre public pour prendre un terme
très générique mais même si ce n'est pas
exactement ce qui est écrit mais c'est
le sens général si
nous combinons ces dispositions avec
l'instruction du 3 août dernier par
laquelle vous indiquez à vos services
que vous souhaitez que soit placé en
centre de rétention administrative donc
ensuite éloigné ou expulsé des personnes
qui sont effectivement celles qui
causent le plus de troubles à l'ordre
public ça dessine un paysage qui n'est
pas très clairement indiqué dans le
texte mais qui je crois ressort du trail
d'audition notamment que nous avons pu
faire qui est que aujourd'hui on va
prioriser l'expulsion l'éloignement des
personnes qui sont celles
trouble l'ordre public en France que
faisons-nous des autres c'est à dire
celles qui sont en situation irrégulière
et qui font obser l'objet de décision
d'éloignement
et dans la droite ligne de cette
question l'article 12 prévoit que on ne
pourra plus passer en centre de
rétention administrative les mineurs de
16 ans
comment assurer l'éloignement des
familles si on ne peut plus passer
ensemble de restention administrative
les mineurs et pourquoi cette restreint
au centre de rétention administrative et
pas aux locaux de restauration
administrative ou zone d'attente qui
sont aussi des lieux où on retient des
mineurs
merci Monsieur Votre Carrère deux
questions également
réparties quittablement une pour
Monsieur dussoft une pour Monsieur
Darmanin pour Monsieur Darmanin je
souhaiterais monsieur mise à l'intérieur
vous
interrogez sur la pertinence ou pas de
venir vous aider sur la question des
laisser passer consulaires et notre idée
serait de raisonner quant au fait que
l'immigration n'est pas un sujet de la
France mais un sujet de la France et des
pays sources et le Sénat avait vu
monsieur le ministre avec une certaine
satisfaction
notre pays menait une politique de
réduction des visas en disant en termes
de réciprocité au pays concernés cher
ami soyez un petit peu plus attentif aux
demandes de laisser passer
consulaire que vous ne le faites
actuellement nous avons vu que cette
politique de réduction du nombre de visa
avait été abandonnés nous n'avons pas
constaté cependant dans nos visites dans
les préfectures une grande amélioration
de l'obtention de laisser passer
consulaire peut être très très à la
marche concernant l’algérie mais c'est
vraiment à la marge et dont nous nous
posons la question de savoir si nous
vous rendrions services si nous avions
l'idée d'un amendement qui quelque part
conduirait le Parlement à donner une
orientation on pourrait même être
quelquefois un peu plus prescriptif
quand au nombre de visa quand au nombre
de types de séjour qui pourrait être
autorisés chaque année dans notre pays
et donc en d'autres termes est-ce que
une telle position du Parlement
définissant un chiffre annuel vous
rendrez service dans la négociation
amicale mais dont on imagine qu'il y a
aussi une part de rapport de force assez
importante ce rapport de force qu'on
aimerait vous aider à créer à travers un
tel système
monsieur dussobe vous vous doutez qu'on
ne peut pas échapper monsieur ministre
pardon excusez-moi ma femme la
familiarité de mon propre monsieur le
ministre
on ne peut pas échapper à l'article 3 et
nous avons un peu de mal à comprendre où
vous voulez aller si vous voulez aller à
une régularisation de la situation de
gens qui travaillent dans notre pays qui
sont là depuis assez longtemps et qui
sont placés dans une situation
d'illégalité ou de clandestinité on peut
comprendre votre souhait de voir la
société française regardez les réalités
en face et
[Musique]
régulariser si tel est le cas
quel est l'intérêt des
mesures
successives de sanctions que vous
proposez aux employeurs puisque vous
dites à un employeur si on régularise
ton salarié qui est donc en une
situation d'inégalité etc on ne te
garantit un contrôle et tu auras une
sanction pénale peut-être probablement
tu auras une amende aussi on rajoute une
amende administrative et on va lui
épargner éventuellement la fermeture
administrative on voit bien qu'il y a
une contradiction dans le texte entre
votre souhait de régularisation et les
différentes sanctions suivantes d'autres
termes si il doit y avoir régularisation
il faut à ce moment-là l'assumer avec
une amnistie à l'égard de l'employeur du
style mon cher employeur Vous
régularisez vous offrez un contrat du
indéterminé à votre salarié à des
conditions normales et il n'y a pas de
sanction il n'y a pas de sanction pénale
qui est une manière de vous dire et de
dire aussi à mes collègues en l'état
actuel du texte nous ne pensons pas
qu'il y aura énormément de demandes
d'application de cet article 3 si par
contre je ne suis pas convaincu par
cette idée directrice que la
régularisation d'une bonne chose et si
je pense deux choses
si je pense que vous faites courir un
risque à notre pays en termes d'appel
d'air aussi je pense que vous faites
courir un autre risque au pays en termes
de trappe à bas salaire je vais vous
demander d'aller un petit peu plus loin
si je pense que il y a un risque d'appel
d'air je peux le combler en vous disant
mais on va limiter le nombre
annuellement on a dit il y en aura
encore une fois pas énormément il y a
donc pas de difficultés à fixer un
objectif il n'y a pas de problème
d'inconstitutionnalité on est en matière
professionnelle donc je peux traiter par
le nombre que pensez-vous d'une telle
hypothèse je peux également traité par
la réduction du délai parce qu'il y a
quand même une curiosité dans l'état
actuel de l'article 3 c'est que vous
proposez jusqu'au 31 décembre 2026 alors
que nous parlons d'une régularisation si
vous permettez la formule de stock si je
fais une régularisation je la fais à un
moment donné là si j'étais malicieux ce
que je ne suis pas monsieur le ministre
et si j'étais pasteur je pourrais
interpréter la disposition vous avez
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2026 je ferai mon
petit calcul le texte me donne la
possibilité de demander ma
régularisation au bout de trois ans si
je me dépêche de faire venir mes
excellents clients de tel ou tel pays
d'ici le 31 décembre 2023 2024 2025-2026
ils seront dans les temps pour demander
la pour demander le temps la
régularisation je me pose donc la
question de comment
voudrais vous pousser un peu dans votre
tranchement pour nous dire comment
éviter ce risque d'appel d'air et si je
crains ce qui serait plutôt mon analyse
monsieur le ministre pour tout vous dire
si je crains la trappe à bas salaire
j'ai deux sujets
qui nous mettent vraiment mal à l'aise
sur la rédaction article de l'article 3
le
fond du sujet c'est que vous demandez à
traiter une question économique celle
des métiers en tension
par une disposition régalienne si
l'année qui est un texte en matière
d'immigration traité de l'économie par
un texte régalien
ça va pas très bien ensemble et donc on
voit bien qu'il nous manque une
articulation
par rapport à la négociation collective
si demain on veut que nos concitoyens
aillent vers des emplois qui n'ont pas
trop envie d'occuper actuellement et qui
dit moins de d'étrangers pour l'occuper
on voit bien qu'il y a des problèmes de
formation on voit bien qu'il y a des
problèmes de rémunération donc si dans
cet article 3 on avait un lien avec la
négociation collective et avec donc la
responsabilité conjointe entre les
employeurs les salariés et la société
j'avoue que je serai plus à l'aise et
dernier élément et j'arrête dans
l'exercice en honte à vous changer si
vous me permettez cette formule sur cet
article 3 c'est encore plus bizarre pour
des gens qui comme moi craignent un peu
cette trappe à mes salaires que vous
créez un nouveau type de séjour bon ça
c'est encore un autre sujet mais vous
créez un titre de séjour métier en
tension qui va être opposable c'est à
dire que si je suis en situation
irrégularité
je vais et j'estime pouvoir bénéficier
des dispositions de l'article 3 je vais
pouvoir s'agissant d'une disposition de
l'endroits je vais pouvoir saisir le
juge administratif de ma demande de
régularisation et on va faire du juge
administratif là où c'était le préfet
avec les circulaires Valls on va dans
une situation où le juge administratif
va devenir le juge de cette régulation
économique vous m'accorderez qu'il est
pas vraiment quand même
outillé pour cet élément donc que je
regarde l'article 3 en résumé
excusez-moi d'avoir été un petit peu
long mais c'est encore une fois pour
vous pousser un peu dans votre
retranchement si je suis favorable à la
régularisation je n'ai pas satisfaction
dans l'article 3 si je crains l'appel
d'air je suis pas plus satisfait si je
crains la trappe à bas salaire je n'ai
pas ma réponse dans l'actualité donc
c'est un une disposition qui me paraît
perfectible et auriez-vous des propos
solutions pour tenir compte de ces
différents points de vue dont je peux
imaginer que vous les retrouverez un
moment donné dans les débats devant le
Sénat merci merci monsieur laporteur je
vais donner la parole au ministre je
voudrais indiquer à tout le monde que on
a encore à peu près une heure d'horloge
il y a déjà 5 collègues qui sont
inscrits pour qu'on la parole d'autres
donc voilà c'est pour vous dire à peu
près du temps dont nous disposons bien
monsieur Darmanin la concision monsieur
le Président je vais essayer d'être
concis mais de répondre évidemment aux
interrogations de nos rapporteurs
peut-être avec l'autorisation de
ministre du sol sur la première partie
de la première question de Madame
jourdat sur le niveau de langue
moi je n'ai rien contre le fait que ce
soit législatif donc qui peut plus peut
le mot on verra ce que dira le Conseil
constitutionnel mais en tout cas vous ne
trouverez pas de points de bloquant de
la part du gouvernement donc je n'ai
rien au fait que ce soit maître
effectivement dans la loi moi je
pencherai pour le niveau de langue plus
important la 2 madame la sénatrice à
condition que nous conditionions un A2
oral parce que je pense que ce pour le
coup très demandée aux étrangers qui
arrivent sur notre sol de pouvoir écrire
à la deux en français je pense que il
est pas tout à fait certain d'ailleurs
que l'ensemble des personnes qui
je veux dire ont déjà des titres de
séjour où sont eux-mêmes Français
sachent parfaitement répondre à cette
interrogation de la 2 à l'écrit mais la
2 à l'oral je pense que c'est un niveau
d'exigence quand même important voir
très voir très important je suis pas là
pour rentrer dans le débat entre les LR
monsieur le sénateur de Brest
la question du A2 à l'oral moi je pense
que c'est au niveau d'exigence
importante qui veut donc aussi dire que
les moyens de l'État doit être mobilisés
pour permettre aux gens de passer cet
examen mais encore une fois je n'ai rien
contre le fait que vous proposiez par
principe le fait qu'il puisse être
législatif sur l'assimilation elle
parallèle que vous avez fait madame
assadri je pense qu'il est pas tout à
fait juste si je peux me permettre
certes dans l'assimilation il y a aussi
la langue pour devenir français mais il
y a beaucoup d'examens il y a un exemple
plus complet sur les valeurs de la
République le qu'on pas à l'étranger qui
aurait une carte uranuelle par exemple
vous savez qu'on demande aujourd'hui qui
est Jeanne d'Arc qui est Napoléon cité 5
ministres du gouvernement pas sûr que
tous les Français savent absolument
répondre à la question des ministres de
Brest et par ailleurs cité trois plats
français bon donc les entretiens
d'affiliation on se repose sur d'autres
choses que sur que sur la que sur la
langue
bien sûr mais je comprends votre votre
demande et je n'y vois pas
d'inconvénient sur le deuxième point sur
la procédure évoquée par Monsieur
bonnekria moi je partage pas votre
opinion et sauf à évidemment
et sans vexée président buffet bien sûr
bien sûr le président du fait dans dans
la commission ainsi que ce qu'avait
évoqué stade repris par le président la
serre c'était on passe de 12 procédures
à trois et en gros votre question
revient à dire pourquoi fait de 12 à 4
si j'ai bien compris votre votre demande
bon nous on crée une quatrième procédure
justement pour je fais le lien avec
Madame la question suivante pour l'ordre
public
et on dit que justement il faut réduire
pour un certain nombre de cas qui me
paraisse pas contrairement à ce que vous
dites majoritaire monsieur le sénateur
mais on doit pouvoir réduire le délai de
présence sur sa nationale de ces
personnes qui ont un deuté pour
appliquer cette parce que justement nous
avons laissé passer consulaire
d'ailleurs vous constater que le projet
du gouvernement c'était 48 heures et
après discussion avec le Conseil d'État
qui n'a pas trouvé que notre quatrième
procédure était était
inimaginable dans le droit nous a dit
plutôt 72 heures et nous pensons au
contraire que nous allons fluidifier
cette partie particulière des étrangers
que qui qui doit être expulsé parce
qu'il propose une menace à l'ordre
public particulière et que un certain
nombre de personnes ne passe pas par le
crâne passe pas par le L.A de passe pas
par la signature résidence pour expulser
fort heureusement nous arrivons à
expulser un certain nombre d'étrangers
avec certains types de nationalité dans
certains cas bien sûr c'est pas le cas
général si j'ose dire directement une
fois que le qtf a été a été notifié et
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup d'étrangers
qui soit ne font pas le recours et donc
vous aurez compris aussi que l'implicite
c'était la réduction du délai c'était
pour éviter évidemment d'avoir trop laps
de temps de recours qui nous permet
malheureusement de ne pas pouvoir
expulser les personnes il y a aussi ça
dans la non exécution des auditeurs mais
aussi d'être pour bien signaler au
tribunaux administratif que notre
demande est express par définition et
qu'elle est et qu'elle est prioritaire
la difficulté d'aujourd'hui mais je
pense que chacun ça le constate c'est
que le tribunal administratif le juge
administratif il sait plus très bien ce
qui relève du priorité et pas du
prioritaire dans la base du contentieux
qui lui arrive donc on a essayé de du
classifier ce qui du point de vue de
l'intérêt public au nom du gouvernement
et du législateur si vous l'adopter
relève de la priorité et donc moi je
tiens à mon quatrième ma quatrième
procédure on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler je voudrais dire ici et
sortirai évidemment les les
compétences législateur que vous êtes
que ça a été le fruit d'un très long
travail de discussion avec le Conseil
d'État parce que dans ce texte
particulier chacun concentraque le est à
la fois bien sûr le juge du droit tel
que de le proposons mais aussi un peu
intéressé à la faire voilà certains
pourraient dire d'ailleurs qui qu'il se
jugent lui-même en jugeant le texte que
nous proposons c'est là pour ça que je
n'étais pas tout à fait d'accord avec le
fait que un certain nombre de
disposition comme la territorisation de
la CNDA ne méritait pas d'être légitime
parce que je considère personnellement
que si nous prenons des décrets en
Conseil d'État et il y a une petite
conflit d'intérêt dans notre histoire
mais on aura l'occasion d'en reparler
sans doute dans nos débats donc moi je
tiens à ces quatrième procédure j'espère
dans les débats et dans vos éditions
démontrer son intérêt sur Madame madame
Jordan me dit bon alors voilà vous
prioriser les les personnes dangereuses
pour le bien public vous mettez vos
rétablissez à double peine mais du coup
comment on fait avec tous les autres
puisque grosso modo vous mettez cela en
crin et pas les autres alors la
difficulté qui est mise à l'intérieur et
surtout lorsqu'il est arrivé il y a 2
ans et demi c'est qu'il y avait pas
beaucoup de place de cras pour pour deux
grandes raisons la première c'est qu'un
la structurellement pas beaucoup en
France alors comparativement à d'autres
pays européens il y en a beaucoup mais
relativement sans doute un petit
d'expulsion à voir il y en a pas assez
et puis deuxièmement je suis arrivé au
Miss à l'intérieur au moment du covid où
les restrictions sanitaires
s'appliquaient également bien sûr en
place de crabe et troisièmement
répondant à votre question ainsi pour
les mineurs qu'est-ce qui prend la place
dans les crans également et pour
d'autres raisons je pourrais évoquer
pourquoi il faudrait supprimer en effet
la présence des personnes de moins de 16
ans dans les centres de rétroses
administratives c'est pas nécessaire son
métier pour une petite migratoire
efficace parce qu'il y a des lieux
familles et c'est du famille ils
prennent des places que pourrait être
libéré largement pour les délinquants
étrangers qui sont à 98% des hommes je
suis obligé de le constater avec vous
donc le but de l'intérieur il avait pas
cette place structurellement pas cette
place à cause du covid et par ailleurs
des lieux familles où il n'y a personne
ou pas grand monde puisque je voudrais
dire voler chiffre à madame la sénatrice
en 2022 il y a eu 107 mineurs en
métropole donc voilà la question qui se
pose c'est Mayotte on reparler
évidemment si vous le souhaitez mais en
métropole en fait une politique
migratoire sans mettre des mineurs dans
les centres de rétention administratifs
bien évidemment j'aurais reparlé donc
d'abord qu'est-ce qu'on essaye de faire
d'abord on essaie de dire parmi les
priorités parce que quand il y a des
difficultés on essaie de faire des
priorités moi je pense qu'il vaut mieux
concentrer nos moyens pour expulser des
étrangers qui sont en situation
irrégulière qui sont délinquants que
l'étranger en situation régulière qui
n'est pas délinquant d'ailleurs je vais
pas faire ici une revue de détail mais
je reçois énormément de lettres de tout
bord politique pour me dire moi j'ai un
je connais un jeune Malien 19 ans qui
est formidable dans ma boulangerie il
faut vraiment le régulariser ou j'ai une
infirmière voilà cette infirmière elle
est formidable régularisée d'ailleurs je
constate qu'il y a souvent des
différences entre la position qu'on a en
général sur les étrangers et les
interventions individuelles de chacune
et de chacun
j'ai été Parlement j'ai été
parlementaire j'ai moi-même péché un
maximum mais elle coule pas enfin je
suis bien obligé de le constater bon et
rarement vous m'écrivez pour me dire je
connais un étranger délinquant très bien
il faut me le régulariser en général
vous ne pouvez pas sur ce point et donc
je me dis tiens peut-être que dans la la
liste des personnes que je dois expulser
en premier devant les difficultés
évidemment d'expulser des étrangers
notamment dans le cadre du covid je me
suis dit on va d'abord expulser les
étrangers en situation régulière qui
sont délinquants alors soit qui relèvent
du fspert je rappelle qu'il y a pas si
longtemps que ça notre pays était très
touché par le terrorisme et il est
toujours extrêmement menacé par le
terrorisme soit qu'on appelle nous les
tops c'est-à-dire les étrangers
délinquants de droit commun
tout à l'heure le président du fait me
demandait une péto combien de personnes
sont concernées on a expulsé 800
étrangers inscrits au fspert T
depuis que je suis au ministère de
l'Intérieur et 3500 délinquants
étrangers c'est-à-dire qu'on a multiplié
par 7 le nombre d'étrangers délinquants
qu'on a pu expulser pourquoi parce qu'on
est fait comme vous l'avez dit dans mon
instruction que j'ai donné au préfet au
centre de rétention administratif j'ai
décidé de mettre en priorité quand on a
deux dossiers quelqu'un qui est
dangereux plutôt quelqu'un qui est pas
dangereux parce que si quelqu'un qui est
dangereux qu'attend son expulsion comme
était des crimes vous seriez les
premiers et vous auriez raison bien et
pourquoi il est pas ailleurs que dans un
centre de rétention administratif
ceci étant dit
nous avons
conscience que nous ne pouvons pas
mettre que des étrangers dit dangereux
dans les centres de rétention
administratif et que ces centres de
rétention administratifs ont aussi un
intérêt bien sûr pour les étrangers qui
n'ont pas de casier judiciaire mais qui
méritent d'être expulsé du territoire
national c'est pour ça que nous avons
adopté un amendement du Parlement c'est
en l'occurrence à un moment national que
vous avez confirmé ici même en CMP pour
la création de 3000 places de gras donc
depuis que je suis mise intérieur en
augmenter de 800 le nombre de places de
CRA deuxième construction de ne plus
mettre des mineurs dans les cas donc du
coup je gagne encore des places de
centre de rétrosolucratif puisque
l'espace famille devient un espace homme
où je gagne de la place je maintiens
aussi un syndrome de crack qui était je
pense au département du président de la
commission des lois puisqu'on a ouvert
un cra à Lyon j'ai décidé de laisser
ouvert l'ancien après rénovation avec
une innovation pour la première fois
depuis de très nombreuses années c'est
les gendarmes qui tiennent le Kra et
plus simplement les policiers aux
frontières et puis de nombreux projets
évidemment existent encore donc
je pense que cette priorité aux
étrangers délinquants dans à partir de
l'année prochaine je crois madame la
sénatrice je pense qu'on peut le dire ne
sera pas exclusif dans les centres de
rétention administrative parce que le
Mesnil-Amelot il y en a vers Perpignan
il y en a donc j'en ai dit à Lyon il y
en a un nouveau en Île-de-France vont
permettre d'avoir plus de place de gras
et donc plus de possibilités d'y mettre
des personnes y compris qui ne sont pas
étrangers délinquants il y a aussi des
LRA
donc ces lieux de rétention
administrative je les ai demandé au
préfet n'en faisait pas assez notamment
dans le sud de la France donc c'est les
rats nous permettent de mettre justement
des personnes qui sont pas en tant que
tel dangereuses et permettre justement
de mettre des personnes qui sont en
attente des expulsions et pour répondre
à votre question ce qui est écrit dans
le texte c'est le centre de rétention
administratif pour les mineurs mais il
peut toujours avoir des locaux
administratifs de rétention bien sûr des
lieux comme des LRA de rétention on peut
même imaginer dans certains cas
particuliers des endroits des
assignations à résidence ou cette ou la
maison ou l'appartement évidemment est
gardé par la police nationale quelle est
la difficulté d'appuyer ce frontières la
police aux frontière sa difficulté c'est
pas de garder pendant des semaines des
enfants de 6-7 ans dans un lieu clos
avec des barbelés je pense que chacun
comprend que c'est pas de même manière
de se construire
mais en même temps on voit bien que la
difficulté c'est que la veille de
prendre l'avion il faut pas que
évidemment les personnes utilisent le
moment où ils ont relative liberté pour
pouvoir s'échapper et se soustraire au
contrôle de la police donc le monde dans
lequel je voudrais qu'on évolue si
jamais le Sénat et l'Assemblée venait à
adopter ces dispositions que c'est dans
le cas où une famille et notamment je
parle il s'agit là peut-être d'enfants
en bas âge bien évidemment devait être
expulsé du territoire national et bien
la veille voir même l'avant veille mais
je pense que on sait tout à fait capable
de faire la veille dans un lieu de
rétention spécifique un hôtel par
exemple qui est près d'un aéroport
garder par la police permet de pouvoir
avoir sous la main si j'ose dire la
famille mais ne pas imposer aux jeunes
enfants des images
de centre qui sont quand même assez
carcéraux voilà donc je pense qu'on est
capable de dire pas d'enfants dans les
cas et en même temps d'avoir dans des
locaux de de rétention plus humaine des
plus humains pardon je commence à être
fatigué des gens qui peuvent être gardés
par la police pour évidemment qu'il ne
se soucerait pas au contrôle évidemment
et on renvoie dans leur pays d'origine
enfin sur la question plus générale les
laisser passer consulaires contre les
visas votre question est évidemment
au milieu la difficulté du métier de
mise à l'intérieur et d'immigration
monsieur le rapporteur mais vous le
savez bien moi je n'ai rien contre
disposition législative et j'allais dire
même au contraire j'ai tout pour
Éditions Législatives pourquoi parce que
quand je discute avec mes homologues
étrangers ils me disent nous on respecte
les lois de la République on respecte
les lois de votre pays mais c'est pas
dans les lois de votre pays que ces
visas contre la mission donc je vais
vous dire puisque j'ai parfois entendu
cet argument de la part de mes
homologues dont acte ça me paraît
bizarre de mettre des quotas au sens des
quotas de visa réadmissions à partir de
quand on peut déclencher je voudrais
qu'on en parle un petit peu plus mais
qui est une disposition générale qui
disent voilà la République elle peut pas
accepter de pas avoir de laisser passer
le consulaire un échange faire du visa
moi je suis personnellement pas du tout
pas du tout posé juste peut-être pour
être plus efficace mais pardon d'être un
peu long monsieur le Président Monsieur
pour être très important faut savoir que
la relation diplomatique entre deux pays
c'est pas qu'entre deux ministres de
l'Intérieur malheureusement j'allais
dire et que la discussion diplomatique
elle se fait pas entre laisser passer
consulaire votre visa c'est déjà très
compliqué parce que Visa pour qui visa
pourquoi vous me dites avec gentillesse
on a trouvé que la France est très très
courageuse quand tu as fait des
répression de visa je voudrais pas ici
aussi de redire que tout en encourageant
la restriction de visa en général contre
des laissés passer contre considère
qu'ils étaient pas donnés je ne compte
plus le nombre d'interventions de
parlementaires qui vivait quand même ce
que vous faites avec le Maroc ou avec
l'Algérie avec nos ça nous embête
beaucoup politiquement culturellement
économiquement du contain des parts de
marché dans ces pays bon on peut pas
l'ignorer non plus que nous avons aussi
parfois cette singulière pression mais
par ailleurs il y a d'autres sujets je
pense au développement je sors
complètement de mon rôle mais peut-être
qu'on pourrait penser que et là ma
position n'a pas été validée on atteint
ministériel comme on dit est-ce que on
peut trouver normal que des pays nous
refusent et laisser passer consulaire et
qu'on leur donne beaucoup d'aide de
développement alors que manifestement il
n'acceptent pas le retour de leurs
étrangers en situation irrégulière c'est
une question importante intéressante
qu'on va se poser donc si vous faites un
amendement monsieur le sénateur je ne
saurais trop vous recommandé de regarder
l'ensemble de la politique de notre pays
et pas simplement des relations entre
mises à l'intérieur parce que quel
problème ils intérieur quand il discute
avec son homologue c'est qu'il parle de
laisser passer consulaire mais parle
aussi de coopération antiterroriste il
parle aussi de renseignements de
coopération judiciaire et que parfois il
vaut mieux la sécurité des Français que
de se fâcher sur une question de visa de
rémission mais si le Parlement je ne
fais qu'appliquer les lois du du
Parlement s'il va le voter je pense que
ce serait à mon avis une bonne pierre
pour les futurs négociations des mises à
l'intérieur
point monsieur bonnecarer n'aura pas de
mal à retrouver dans ces tablettes un
amendement qui a été voté en 2018 à
l'initiative des hautes serviteurs qui
n'avait pas eu de bonne suite mais je me
souviens d'une question d'actualité
laquelle vous aviez répondu
favorablement à cette idée on va la
reprendre naturellement Monsieur duple
Merci monsieur le Président sur les deux
points évoqués par les rapporteurs
d'abord sur la question de Madame
Jourdan est-ce qu'il est normal en tout
cas je réformer votre interrogation que
l'employeur prenne en charge les
conséquences d'une politique migratoire
je ne partage pas l'entrée dans dans la
discussion dans ce sujet pour deux
raisons d'abord nous parlons uniquement
des étrangers non communautaires et il
faut savoir ça permet de relativiser
l'importance ou le volume de ce dont
nous parlons que les étrangers non
communautaire occupent moins de 4% du
total de l'emploi en France c'est très
variable d'un métier à l'autre mais en
moyenne on est autour de 3,8%.
l'étranger communautaire parmi le total
des salariés sur le territoire français
et donc ça ça permet d'avoir une cible
si je puis dire relativement sachant que
parmi eux beaucoup se constitutions
régulières depuis très longtemps et ont
déjà satisfait aux obligations
d'intégration et de maîtrise du français
la deuxième chose c'est que nous parlons
justement d’étranger non communautaires
et donc la présence de ces étrangers
dans les entreprises et est à la fois le
fruit des décisions de recrutement avec
une nuance que j'apporte moi-même dans
mon propos c'est que nous sommes
actuellement dans une période de tension
de recrutement ce qui peut amener à des
choix particuliers ou différents de ceux
que les chefs d'entreprise faisaient
précédemment mais c'est une présence qui
est choisie par celui qui recrute par le
recrutement d'un étranger dans
communautaire et d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'entreprises le disaient tout à l'heure
nous invite à aller même plus avant que
ce que nous proposons le MIH qui a
communiqué aujourd'hui dit à la fois
soutenir et vouloir aller plus loin en
matière régularisation de salariés
réguliers mais dans la présence sur le
territoire était régulière et nous
demande même de faciliter les conditions
d'entrer sur le territoire ce qui n'est
pas prévu par ce texte au-delà de la
simplification de la carte talent que
j'ai déjà évoqué
l'état fait déjà beaucoup en matière de
formation beaucoup en matière de
formation dans la mesure où avant même
la mise en oeuvre de la loopmie des
moyens supplémentaires consacrés à
l'insertion et à l'intégration par la
langue il y a des dizaines de milliers
de places de formation en français qui
sont ouvertes par l'État et qui
permettent à des étrangers allophones de
pouvoir se former et ainsi d'acquérir un
niveau de français et par ailleurs de la
du temps libérée et des quelques heures
de temps de travail que nous allons
demander aux employeurs concernés de
libérer pour permettre le suivi des
cours nous souhaitons aussi que les
différentes entreprises et les branches
professionnelles puissent s'intégrer
nous proposons d'écrire de manière
explicite la possibilité
d'inscrire dans leur plan de formation
dans leur plan de développement des
compétences des modules spécifiques pour
leurs salariés à nos fun puisqu'il y a
des salariés le fun et prévoir que les
plans de formation débranchent comme les
entreprises puissent prévoir des modules
spécifiques pour les salariésophobes
sera aussi une réponse à portée apporter
à ceci je crois que
d'une manière peut-être plus générale ou
si on sort du Sud du seul sujet de
financement
par la libération du temps de
compétences il y a quelques remarques
que l'on peut faire aussi d'abord une
marque pour dire que le caractère un peu
contraignant de cette libération de
temps pour participer à des obligations
des formations en français limite le
côté armé de raisin et le côté recours
avec main d'oeuvre étrangère non
communautaire avec comme objectif et une
pression à la baisse des salaires la
deuxième remarque est que nous avons
beaucoup réfléchi autour de ce sujet là
pour voir comment demander aux
entreprises qui par ailleurs nous
demandent d'avoir plus facilement accès
au recrutement de salarié non
communautaire de participer à la
formation française et nous avons fait
le choix de vous proposer le fait de
libérer du temps sur le temps de travail
plutôt que de créer une nouvelle taxe
qui aurait pu être imaginé pour financer
ces mêmes formations et le temps le
temps nécessaire et enfin il y a un
dernier point que que je porte à votre
réflexion qui
fait que dans le code du travail tel
qu'il s'applique que les salariés soient
français européen ou non communautaire
l'employeur est une obligation de
formation pour l'adaptation des salariés
au poste occupé et pour les salariés
allophones ça renvoie aussi à la
maîtrise de la langue nécessaire pour à
la fois la compréhension des
instructions et la communication avec
l'ensemble des équipes ça fait le lien
d'une certaine manière quand on parle
d'obligation avec les interrogations de
monsieur le sénateur bonne Carrère sur
l'article 3 quel est notre objectif
notre objectif n'est pas de susciter un
flux de manière très claire et je
partage comme vous le fait qu'il n'y a
pas d'appel d'air avec ce titre de
séjour nouveau pas d'appel d'air parce
qu'il faudrait pour qu'il y en apelle
d'air que des étrangers communautaires
non communautaires pardon ayant
connaissance de l'existence d'un titre
de séjour spécifique prennent la
décision de venir sur le territoire
national avec l'objectif de s'y
maintenir en situation irrégulière
pendant au moins trois ans en l'état du
texte d'exercer un métier pendant au
moins 8 mois en état du texte dans une
filière en tension et en ayant une
espèce de de pré connaissance trois ans
quatre ans cinq ans à l'avance de l'état
de la liste des métiers en tension
puisque cette liste émettait en tension
en vocation à être renouvelée et révisée
intervalle régulier lorsqu'on a dit cela
est rappelé ces critères d'accès au
titre de séjour la question de l'appel
d'air ne se pose pas véritablement il y
a une question que vous avez posée par
contre qui renvoie puisqu'on est sur une
logique de régularisation de salariés
qui ont un contrat de travail qui ont
une activité régulière mais une
situation personnelle irrégulière qui
renvoie à la question des sanctions pour
l'employeur il est bien évident et je
préfère le préciser devant vous que les
employeurs qui verraient dans leurs
effectifs des personnes en situation
irrégulière obtenir une régularisation
par ce type de séjour qui employeur qui
ne connaissent pas la situation
administrative de leurs salariés il n'y
a pas lieu de les sanctionner ça
n'existe pas dans notre esprit ça ne
doit pas exister dans l'application la
volonté que nous avons de renforcer les
sanctions concerne les employeurs qui
délibérément
recrute des personnes en situation
irrégulière et la le fait de créer une
sanction administrative permet aussi à
la fois la proportionnalité et une
liberté d'appréciation de l'autorité
administrative j'ai dit à des seins tout
à l'heure que beaucoup des personnes en
situation irrégulière mais travaillant
régulièrement sont des personnes qui en
réalité ont signé un contrat de travail
à un moment où ils étaient titulaires
d'un titre de séjour avec celui-ci n'a
pas été renouvelé nous ne pouvons pas
faire grief au chef d'entreprise de
manière automatique ça serait injuste
d'une certaine manière lui-même ne le
senta pas forcément et je dis en
ajoutant qu'il arrive parfois même à
l'état de devoir mettre fin à des
contrats de travail découvrant que tel
ou telle contractuel a perdu le bénéfice
d'un titre de séjour et donc ça nous
amène aussi une forme d'humilité de
compréhension de la situation des
employeurs dans le secteur privé et donc
c'est vraiment
l'articulation vous cherchez entre
l'article 3 et l'article 8 n'existe pas
en réalité puisque l'article 8 vise
véritablement à sanctionner plus
fortement ceux qui délibérément de
manière réitérer en recours à des
personnes en situation irrégulière pour
pour les employés sur la question de
l'amélioration du texte pour permettre
notamment au Parlement
d'avoir une capacité d'évaluation qui
soit améliorée vous avez évoqué la
limitation vous avez évoqué la question
du calendrier moi je regarderai avec
évidemment beaucoup d'attention toutes
les initiatives parlementaires en la
matière pour voir comment on peut
apporter les garanties que certains ont
certaines d'entre vous souhaiteraient
exiger et donc ça n'est pas une réponse
en disant nous avons une disposition
sinon nous l'aurions inscrite dans la
loi mais évidemment nous sommes
favorables à y travailler et il y a une
question que vous avez évoqué ensuite
qui est
deux questions pardon et j'en terminerai
par là qui concerne d'une part le
caractère opposable du titre de séjour
et finalement le fait qu'un employeur
puisse découvrir ou voir apparaître dans
ses effectifs quelqu'un qui aurait
demandé au juge administratif
l'obtention d'un titre de séjour pour
métier en tension si d'aventure la
préfecture au prix de qui la sollicité
ne l'avait pas attribué je pense que le
fait de mettre dans la loi comme nous
vous le proposons des critères
d'éligibilité à ce type de séjour en
matière de renvoi une liste de métiers
en tension qui fait l'objet d'une
décision administrative puisqu'elle fait
l'objet d'une publication par arrêter
ministérielle le fait d'inscrire dans la
loi les
temps dans l'occupation de l'emploi que
sur la pour la présence sur le
territoire et de déterminer par la loi
comme nous vous le proposons ce qui
relève des critères retenus outils de la
présence sur le territoire et ce qui
n'en relève pas notamment dans le cadre
de ceux qui ont un moment ou un autre
été demandeurs d'asile c'est la
meilleure garantie qu'il n'y ait pas
véritablement d'opposable ou que ça ne
soit pas de possibilités ou que ce ne
soit pas un nid à contentieux puisque
nous proposons contrairement à la
circulaire valse notamment qui relève de
discrétionnaire nous proposerons au
Parlement de fixer les critères de
manière extrêmement précise sur qui a
droit ou pas à la carte et je pense que
ça diminue le risque de contentieux et
l'employeur ne serait pas tenu ni à au
paiement d'une sanction ni à la
délivrance d'un CDI s'il ne le souhaite
pas puisque il est libre évidemment de
donner
de proposer et de signer un CDI ou pas
avec son salarié
la deuxième chose que vous avez évoquée
et dont je parle lequel je termine
concerne la question des trappes à bas
salaires aujourd'hui en réalité c'est la
situation que nous connaissons qui est
une forme de trappe à bas salaire le
fait que un certain nombre de salariés
en situation régulière puisse être dans
une suite dans une puissance d'avoir une
présence sur le territoire qui elle est
irrégulière l'aimait peut les mettre en
tout cas dans une situation de
vulnérabilité et cette situation de
vulnérabilité est plutôt
la cause de la trappe à bas salaire à
l'inverse la régularisation et
l'obtention d'un titre de séjour oblige
à minima au salaire minima au minimum
conventionnel de bronches et permet
d'aligner pardon pour l'expression les
conditions d'emploi de ces personnes sur
les conditions d'emploi prévues par les
conventions collectives donc c'est
plutôt un aspect protecteur je pense
plutôt que créateur de trappe à bas
salaire et je n'inclus pas dans la
réflexion même si ça existe sur le
territoire les personnes qui sont dans
une double situation de travail non
déclaré et de situation régulière pour
lesquelles il peut y avoir notamment de
la part d'employeur particulièrement
délinquants des situations de
d'exploitation et parfois même d'un
service vous avez renvoyé à l'idée d'un
rôle des branches et d'une forme de
négociation collective je ne pense pas
que nous puissions la retenir pour la
définition des métiers en tension dans
la mesure où il y a un appareil
statistique qui permet d'après la loi
qui crée en tension de mesurer les
tensions de recrutement par contre pour
ce qui concerne
l'accompagnement l'intégration et y
compris les questions relatives à la
formation des salariés concernés je
pense qu'effectivement et sans me
substituer aux partenaires sociaux qui
gère ses accords de branche évidemment
je pense qu'il serait utile
effectivement que les partenaires
sociaux fassent ce travail branchent par
branche pour prévoir des modalités
d'accompagnement et de bonnes
intégration des salariés et ainsi
apporter un certain nombre de réponses
aux interrogations que vous avez
partagées
merci Monsieur Louise pour cette réponse
complète on va donner la parole aux uns
et aux autres alors
Monsieur Alain Richard monsieur
Jean-Yves Lecomte Madame Brigitte
l'herbier madame jacquino strange
brignot Madame Valérie Boyer et Monsieur
Philippe de Brest monsieur Richard
monsieur le ministre de l'Intérieur
est-ce que vous pensez que les réformes
les améliorations qui figurent dans ce
projet de loi
permettront de limiter le flux des
mineurs
isolées entrant en France à travers un
système organisé qui soit artisanal ou
qui soit malheureusement
un système beaucoup plus large et
mafieux
sachant que une partie de ces entrées se
font
de façon irrégulière elle-même ne passe
pas par la police de la rue des
frontières ni en France ni dans un autre
pays d'entrée et par conséquent est-ce
que vous voyez d'autres outils qui
permettraient de freiner ce mouvement
parce que je crains quand même qu'il
souhaite en croissance
notamment à travers une meilleure
meilleure repérage de
l'identité réelle de ces jeunes
merci c'est ministre monsieur Jean-Yves
Leconte
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur des
ministres
5 5 points la vie du Conseil d'État il
est indiqué sur la renouvellement des
titres pluriannuels que près d'un quart
des étrangers qui suivent la formation
linguistique n'atteint pas le niveau A1
à l'insu à l'issue du parcours
d'intégration républicaine alors qu'elle
est éligible à une carte de séjour plus
réelle est-ce que ça veut dire qu'avec
la disposition qui est prévue dans le
projet de loi finalement on allait on va
précariser la situation de personnes qui
sont incapables finalement de de
répondre à cette exigence alors que
souvent finalement pour arriver à se
débrouiller en France ils ont besoin
finalement de l'accompagnement de leurs
enfants est-ce que c'est vraiment en
précarisant qu'on intègre deuxième
question sur les guichets asiles
sans avoir d'objections de principe je
m'interroge vraiment sur un point
comment prendre en compte dans les
préfectures à la question de la
vulnérabilité dès lors que on saute
l'étape finalement
de la rédaction d'un récit et que tout
se fait finalement à la préfecture
comment est-ce qu'on gère la
vulnérabilité en particulier en donnant
la possibilité d'être accueilli par une
personne de l'OFPRA qui serait du même
sexe que le que le demandeur et en
matière d'interprétariat et deuxième
question lié à ces guichets asiles
comment est-ce que vous ne ferez pas
contenu des difficultés de de cette
partie de ce qui se passerait dans les
guichets préfectures l'étape limitante
qui limiterait le nombre de rendez-vous
dans les préfectures et qui finalement
allongerait les capacités
rendrai plus difficile les capacités des
préfectures d'accueillir un maximum de
demandeurs de demande d'asile dans un
temps limité
sur la question des régularisations
qu'est-ce que vous faites finalement des
autres dispositions de la circulaire
valse c'est ce que la circulaire vase
sera remplacée puisque il y a une partie
des choses qui seront traitées par un
titre de plein droit qu'est-ce que vous
faites avec cette avec les autres les
autres aspects comment vous traitez
malgré surtout la situation des
travailleurs des plateformes parce que
c'est pas parce que demain on interdit à
une personne en situation irrégulière de
devenir auto-entrepreneur qui en a pas
qu'ils l'ont fait auparavant on ne
résout pas finalement l'ensemble des
difficultés avec la disposition que vous
prenez sur les autos entrepreneurs donc
qu'est-ce qu'on fait les travailleurs
des plateformes et ce qu'ils ont
vocation finalement à rester dans la
situation telle qu'il est tel qu'il est
aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire sans sans
solution
je suis aussi à étonné ça fait un petit
peu de temps que je fais la commission
des lois mais petit à petit on parlait
bon on parlait beaucoup des centres de
rétention administrative depuis quelques
mois on parle des LRA des lieux de
rétention administrative qui sont moins
identifiés moins connus pas vérifie pas
alors est-ce que c'est une ce serait
quand même assez préoccupant d'avoir de
plus en plus de lieux de privation des
libertés dans notre pays sans qu'il soit
réellement
identifié est-ce qu'il y a quelque chose
à revoir de ce point de vue là parce que
c'est une inquiétude on on va de plus en
plus regarder ce se passe dans les cas
et voilà d'autres lieux de privation de
liberté semblent de plus en plus se
développer vous l'indiquez d'ailleurs
dans une de vos circulaires du mois de
du mois d'août enfin dernière question
vous avez évoqué les aspects européens
il y a quelques l'année dernière on
pensait que le système entrée sortie
Schengen Ethias serait mis en place
avant la fin de cette année le dernier
Conseil européen nous indique que ça
sera mis en place aussi vite que
possible ce qui veut dire en langage
européen qu'on n'a pas de délai donc
voilà qu'est-ce qui se passe réellement
de ce côté-là est-ce que ça sera
réellement mis en place avant les JO
merci Monsieur Leconte Madame Brigitte
l'herbier puis madame sage Brignoud
monsieur le ministre je voudrais revenir
sur l'ordre public
justement ces derniers temps on en a
parlé d'autant plus beaucoup de
nouvelles drogues beaucoup de produits
stupéfiants sur le sol français
se développe beaucoup de reportages qui
nous montrent que les jeunes africains
en situation irrégulière font venir sur
le sol français des produits toujours
nouveaux toujours plus plus dangereux
alors moi ce qui me
m'interroge c'est savoir si
diplomatiquement on peut pas avoir des
des prérogatifs plus sévères concernant
ces ces pays concernant le
l'intégration de de ces de ces
ressortissants
il me semble difficile d'envisager la
régularisation de nombreux jeunes de
telle ou tel pays sachant que
beaucoup de filières s'organisent avec
ces pays et une deuxième remarque
concerne justement tout à l'heure vous
disiez on a eu beaucoup de familles qui
viennent nous voir c'est vrai dans les
permanences
concernant justement souvent ces
instituteurs qui nous disent les enfants
sont bien intégrés à l'école
ils font des études
au collège au lycée voire même
deviennent ingénieurs je pense que ça
fait partie aussi de l'intégration que
de de remarquer ça que de remarquer que
les parents peuvent il y a pas seulement
le
l'apprentissage du français il y a aussi
la responsabilisation des parents et je
pense que dans toutes ces
remarques il faut en prendre compte
aussi
parce que c'est quand même assez gênant
parce que même économiquement à la
limite ces jeunes qui deviennent
ingénieurs qui deviennent médecins ça
peut être aussi intéressant pour pour
notre pays merci même c'est la triste
madame Jacky le singe Bruno oui merci
monsieur le Président je vais essayer
d'être rapide mais c'est un sujet qui me
passionne parce que je suis natrice de
l'Île-de-France et on sait que en gros
50% des premiers admigration sont en
Île-de-France donc je me sens
extrêmement concernée par ce texte deux
choses pour Monsieur le Ministre du ZOP
moi sur l'article 3 j'ai évidemment de
grosses grosses résistances pour deux
raisons la première c'est que je ne sais
pas trop ce que ce sont les métiers en
tension tout comme nous les Français
nous tous les métiers sont en tension
donc partout on cherche du personnel de
l'emploi enfin bon il y a des emplois
qui pourraient être aujourd'hui
voilà moi il y a un sujet de Fond vous
me dites que vous avez parlé discuter
avec des représentants du monde patronal
voilà des organisations patronales je
pense que d'abord si on se faisait la
question du niveau des salaires pour
certains certains effectivement aux
emplois seraient pourvu aujourd'hui sans
problème c'est une vraie question c'est
une vraie question et moi ce qui me gêne
beaucoup dans cet article 3 c'est qu'on
va provoquer une espèce de main d'oeuvre
sous-payée ou peut payer quand même très
docile qui évidemment va pas gêner les
employeurs alors c'est une femme de
droite qui parle aujourd'hui mais c'est
un vrai sujet vous êtes aujourd'hui en
train de vivre exactement ce qu'a vécu
le président Giscard d'Estaing avec le
grand le regroupement familial quand il
a cédé aux pression des employeurs et du
patronat qui leur disent qu'il le disait
à l'époque il faut absolument faire le
grand familial parce qu'autrement tous
les employés d'origine d'engins nous
avons vont repartir c'est la même chose
aujourd'hui on se pose pas la question
de fond du pourquoi aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de branches
professionnelles veulent absolument cet
article 3 pour régulariser du personne
si elles ont aujourd'hui des personnes
qu'elles emploient des personnes en
situation régulière il y a quand même la
circulaire Vans qui permet un certain
nombre de choses et les préfectures y
travaillent je connais vraiment ce sujet
les préfectures essaient de régulariser
via la circulaire vase donc moi j'ai un
vrai sujet et puis sur la responsabilité
du de du patronat en général est-ce que
vous avez abordé avec eux la
problématique de logement d'intégration
de tous ces gens ça de problème à
personne qu'un certain nombre de
personnes dans un étrangères vivent à
5-6 dans un 20 mètres carrés c'est un
vrai sujet ça pose pas souvent de
problèmes aux employeurs ça voilà donc
ça c'est un vrai sujet et en Île de
France c'est un vrai sujet monsieur le
ministre d'armanin a parlé des marchands
de sommeil c'est une réalité c'est une
réalité et je pense que il y a pas de
quoi être fier de dire on va donner des
titres et puis après bah effectivement
qui vivent à 5 dans 20 mètres carrés
c'est pas notre problème bah si c'est le
nôtre en tout cas c'est le problème de
la France donc pour moi c'est un sujet
et cet article 3 me pose un vrai
problème intellectuel un problème de
respect et moi je cautionnerai
absolument pas un article qui
permettrait d'avoir une main d'oeuvre
sous-payée mais qui arrange tout le
monde ça c'est un vrai sujet c'est un
peu je vais aller très loin mais
l'esclavagisme du 21e siècle quand il y
a alors deuxième question deuxième sujet
c'est pour Monsieur Darmanin je voudrais
savoir si un certain nombre d'accord
avec certains pays que nous avons ne
vont pas gêner l'applicabilité réelle de
la loi sur lequel nous discutons
aujourd'hui par exemple l'accord
franco-algérien il y a d'autres accords
il y a encore franc-marocain et à la
coffre en côte tunisien mais celui qui à
mon avis il va perturber l'application
de ce texte intégralement c'est l'accord
franco-algérien est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
monsieur le ministre il y a une
nécessité une légitimité à garder ses
accords ou n'y a-t-il pas un intérêt à
dénoncer ses accords pour que toutes ces
lois s'appliquent partout de la même
manière ça c'est un vrai pour moi c'est
c'est une vraie question c'est un vrai
sujet parce qu'on sait bien les
difficultés que nous avons avec certains
nombres de pays en particulier et puis
ma grève mais d'autres mais qui a
certains noms d'accords qui nous gênent
pour aller jusqu'au bout que nous des
choses voilà que nous écrivons
aujourd'hui et juste une toute petite
question et vous avez parlé monsieur le
ministre monsieur davanin de
du fait que certains nombres d'étrangers
seraient sanctionnés lorsqu'il
refuserait de
d'aller voir un médecin femme ou homme
enfin bon bref on connaît les problèmes
que nous avons dans nos hôpitaux ça
c'est un vrai sujet vous avez eu raison
de le poser mais est-ce que vous vous
êtes aussi posé la question des médecins
parce que nous accueillons dans nos
hôpitaux et en région parisienne
beaucoup qui viennent d'étrangers ça
c'est pas un souci c'est vraiment pas un
souci mais je ne suis pas sûr que tous
ces médecins respectent les règles de la
République et l'école de la République
également parce que d'ailleurs il y a eu
un rapport qui a été fait l'année
dernière sur ce sujet
la difficulté aussi que certains
hôpitaux vivent avec certains médecins
qui ne sont pas les premiers à imposer
et respecter les règles de la République
dans leur fonctionnement de médecins et
je pense que ça c'est un vrai sujet
aussi c'est un sujet qu'il faudra
aborder et c'est un sujet qu'il faut
poser
merci Madame latrice Madame Valérie
Boyer puis Monsieur d'aubresse Merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres je crois savoir au moment même
où nous parlons messieurs les ministres
que l'Algérie a suspendu la délivrance
de laisser passer consulaire c'était une
petite remarque
voilà alors moi ma question porte sur le
trafic d'être humain
vous le savez les Nations unies estiment
à 32 milliards de dollars par an dans le
monde dont 3 milliards pour l'Europe les
profits générés par la traite des êtres
humains au regard de ces chiffres ce
trafic est le troisième le plus lucratif
pour les organisations criminelles après
le trafic de stupéfiant et celui d'armes
la France du fait de sa position
géographique est aujourd'hui à la fois
un pays recevant des victimes de ces
trafics mais aussi un pays de transit de
ces trafics et ne pas agir c'est de
venir complice vous avez d'ailleurs
évoqué votre volonté de mettre fin à ces
trafics puisque vous le savez les
filières de passeurs sont devenues des
experts en détournement de procédure et
c'est vrai que des personnes exploitent
les failles de notre système et abusent
de la générosité nationale et
contrairement à ce que certains disent
ce ne sont pas les frontières qui tuent
la France n'est pas coupable de tout
cela elle a le droit de protéger ses
frontières et doit mener un véritable
combat contre ceux qui prostituent
profitent
les migrants pour combattre ces passeurs
ce n'est pas une simplification de
sécurité mais ça doit être aussi un
devoir de dignité de notre part
aujourd'hui c'est pasteurs sont beaucoup
mieux organisés qu'avant juridiquement
le trafic des migrants est dissocié de
la traite des êtres humains alors que
dans la majorités c'est deux phénomènes
sont liés puisqu'ils s'appuient sur
l'exploitation de l'amendicité de
personnes vulnérables qui tentent de
fuir par tout moyen leur pays ou qui
s'organisent pour envoyer notamment des
mineurs chez nous aussi dès 2015 j'avais
déposé à l'Assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi visant à renforcer la
lutte contre ces trafics de migrants
malheureusement ces propositions de loi
que j'ai toujours formulées à travers
des PPL ou des amendements toujours été
rejetés notamment dans la loi colon mais
permettez-moi de voir encore qu'une fois
des années après le gouvernement reprend
ses propositions je m'en réjouis en
partie et aujourd'hui le fait que pour
toute personne de facilité ou tenter de
faciliter par être directe ou indirect
l'entrée la circulation ou le séjour
irrégulier d'un étranger en France
constitue un délit puni de 5 ans
d'emprisonnement et de 30 000 euros
d'amende c'est vrai que j'avais proposé
de renforcer ses sanctions prévues par
le CESEDA contre ces trafiquants
pasteurs avec la même sévérité que pour
les trafiquants d'être humain je me fais
de licite de voir que huit ans après
vous reprenez cette proposition alors
que vos prédécesseurs si on s'y sont
toujours opposés monsieur le ministre
j'ai deux petites questions précises à
ce sujet pourquoi est-ce qui était
absurde en 2015 et 2018 ne l'est plus
aujourd'hui pourquoi avoir perdu autant
de temps mais plus précisément pourquoi
ne pas renforcer les sanctions pour
l'ensemble des trafiquants d'êtres
humains en effet votre réforme ne
concerne que les suivante j'en ai noté
deux vous me direz si j'ai je me suis
trompé ou pas ça concerne le fait quand
les étrangers auront été exposés à un
risque immédiat de mort ou de blessures
de nature à entraîner une mutilation une
infirmité permanente et ça ne touche que
les dirigeants ou les organisations de
ces groupements et enfin j'ai une
dernière question qui va dans le sens de
ce que Monsieur le Ministre Richard vous
a posé tout à l'heure c'est à dire une
interrogation sur les mineurs étrangers
isolés est-ce que c'est mineur qui pour
la plupart accède à la nationalité
française à l'issue de leur séjour dans
dans les
accueillis par les départements vont
continuer à accéder quasi
automatiquement à la nationalité
française
après votre texte parce que bien
évidemment l'accès la nationalité
française de ces mineurs étrangers
isolés posent de véritables problèmes de
trafic d'êtres humains puisque on sait
très bien que c'est une filière
merci à tous monsieur le sénateur
monsieur le ministre de Brest oui je
vais très rapide vu l'heure monsieur le
Président est-ce que Monsieur Miss
Darmanin peut nous en dire plus sur les
conditions de restriction du
regroupement familial sur lequel il est
passé assez rapidement tu comprends il y
a beaucoup de sujets et c'est quand même
un sujet central et qui fait toujours
l'objet de polémique au Parlement qui
fait toujours l'objet de discussion avec
le Conseil d'État de conseil
constitutionnel et ce qui peut nous dire
où il a mis pourquoi il a mis son
curseur là où il l'a mis et comme il a
dit sur plusieurs radios qui étaient
prêts les plus loin jusqu'où il peut
aller avec ce curseur merci merci
et bien je laisse la parole au ministre
au pluriel et dans l'ordre qu'il
souhaite
bien je vais essayer de répondre à ces
différentes interventions peut-être à
Monsieur Richard et donc et Madame boy
en même temps alors je vais répondre
évidemment celui-là isolé mais il faut
que vous sachiez mais vous le savez bien
sûr à la commission des lois que les
mineurs étrangers minorisés relèvent
strictement de la politique de la
compétence du garde des sceaux pour deux
raisons parce que il y a un sujet état
civil notamment pour connaître
l'identité la question de savoir quelle
est l'état civil des personnes et je ne
suis pas le ministre de l'état civil je
garde des sauts à lire des dispositions
dans la justice qui arrivent sur
justement cet état civil notamment dans
les pays en guerre ou dans les pays qui
auraient pu les dativils ou
l'établissement et deuxièmement c'est
que ce n'est pas le ministre de
l'Intérieur qui expulse les mineurs
c'est une décision judiciaire qui relève
de l'autorité judiciaire en aucun cas
autorité administrative et donc en fait
le ministre de l'Intérieur après bon il
constate ses services qu'il s'agit à
mineur devant soi au corps faut-il
savoir s'il est vraiment mineur ou pas
mineur donc la la la démarche qui
consiste à distinguer ces mineurs
majeurs et du min de l'intérieur une
fois qu'on l'a reconnu comme une heure
il est de la compétence directe de
monsieur le garde des sceaux et donc
pour mettre fin au flux et pour
l'expulsion des personnes qui sont
mineures du territoire national
s'agissant d'édition d'autorité
judiciaire il ne s'agit pas de l'action
du ministre de l'intérieur une fois que
je vous ai mis ces limites évidemment je
peux vous dire que effectivement nous
avons deux mesures qui nous permettent
de penser que ce texte va en très grande
partie permettre le travail au moins de
reconnaissance de la majorité de la
minorité le premier sujet c'est
évidemment la coercition sur les
empreintes puisque vous savez que l'un
des grands sujets c'est évidemment
l'identification des personnes dans
l'état civil que ces empreintes
aujourd'hui ne sont pas prises et que
les gens peuvent les refuser c'est
d'autant plus vrai s'il s'agit de gens
qui sont réputés mineurs j'entends la
demande qui est faite je crois par le
président Retailleau je l'ai lu ça
quelque part dans les journaux d'avoir
une présomption de majorité si le mineur
n'accède pas à aux demandes nombreuses
de tests tests évidemment de d'état
civil vous connaissez les tests osseux
mais qui sait bien qu'il ne fonctionne
pas dans tous les cas et ça c'est un
problème évidemment ou de coercition
évidemment des empreintes je crois que
le président lorsqu'il a formulé sa
proposition il ne savait pas que dans le
texte que nous proposions il y avait la
coercition des empreintes voilà qui
validait d'ailleurs par le Conseil
d'État je pense que l'un n'est pas
incompatible avec l'autre et que si le
Sénat veut rédiger quelque chose qui
ressemble à cela évidemment bien sûr
avec la difficulté constitutionnelle de
voir les choses acceptées je pense que
nous pourrions aller dans ce train
positif puisque nous mettons en place
avec le garde des sceaux une
expérimentation qui se termine à
Bordeaux qui est très intéressantes
puisque à Bordeaux le juge du parquet le
juge du siège le parquet et la police
s'est mis d'accord pour que les mineurs
ne passent plus de tests mais qu'une
reconnaissance de majorité soit établie
par les policiers lorsque il les appelle
dans le centre ville de Bordeaux et que
cette reconnaissance de majorité qui est
injuste qui est juste la foi de l'OPJ
dans son constat parce qu'il voit que la
personne a de la barbe qu'il est
développé enfin bref la distinction
entre la majeure et un mineur vaut
reconnaissance pour le parquet pour le
siège et donc permet d'orienter du côté
de la sanction pénale ce qu'ils étaient
évidemment dans l'espace du code des
mineurs et surtout permet la vie
administrative du majeur et non pas la
vie judiciaire du mineur donc je pense
que cette base de travail sur lequel
nous travaillons sans texte ni loi mais
qui est reconnu par l'autorité
judiciaire peut aussi servir dans la
démarche que pour entreprendre certains
groupes du Sénat donc oui je pense que
ça permettra à la reconnaissance en tout
cas plus efficace beaucoup plus rapide
non ça me permettra pas à meilleur
retour parce que l'un des grands
problèmes c'est le retour c'est
l'identification est-ce qu'il est
marocain est-ce qu'il est algérien ce
qui est tunisien puisque parfois ces
personnes mentent vous le savez bien sur
leur nationalité et nous travaillons
déjà à des reconnaissances puisqu'on
peut le faire parce qu'il y a des
policiers Maroc algériens qui sont dans
les commissariats notamment à Paris
parce que nous regardons les données
téléphoniques pour garder à qui ils ont
appelé sur leur téléphone portable pour
savoir s'ils ont appelé au Maroc ou
s'ils ont appelé en Algérie mais notre
problème n'est pas tellement
l'identification de 900 les deux mesures
nouvelles que je vous propose voir celle
que vous compléteriez que l'application
par l'autorité judiciaire et notamment
par les magistrats libres et
indépendants d'autres pays du retour
alors le garde des sceaux à travers
signé une convention avec le Maroc pour
le retour il me semble mais je pense
qu'il y avait ça pourrait le dire mieux
que moi qu'il n'y a pas eu de décision
judiciaire positive pour le retour de
moi un mineur depuis cette convention
dans le dans le pays d'origine donc je
pense qu'il y a du point de vue du texte
garde des sceaux du texte protection de
l'enfance sans doute des choses qu'on ne
peut pas faire les intérieure puisqu'il
agit comme administratif donc oui pour
l'identification non pour le retour pour
répondre à la question très clairement
de sur Richard et Madame Boyer sur la
question de Monsieur Lecomte
déjà qui d'après le Conseil d'État c'est
tout à fait vrai
ne sont pas dans qu'on prenne très mal
le français ça veut donc dire que vous
les précariserez non mais ils vont
retourner dans leur pays monsieur le
compte le but du jeu c'est de ne pas
donner des titres de séjour aux gens qui
parlent mal ou qui qui comprennent pas
le français donc ça pour ça il y a une
double condition il y a un moyen plus
important à mettre pour l'État dans
l'obligation de moyens donc là ce que
vous a dit Monsieur du socle est tout à
fait important dans cette révolution là
c'est de dire que les gens doivent
prendre leur cours de français désormais
pendant leurs heures de travail c'est
une révolution aussi pour l'étranger qui
aujourd'hui de prendre des cours de
français dès qu'elle est de ces heures
de travail donc vous avez une femme de
ménage qui fait une heure de RER pour
venir travailler qu'à un ou deux enfants
et qui doit refaire une heure de RER
alors que le travail 5 ou 6 jours et
parfois qui est irrégulière dont
exploité parce que un employeur qui
l'exploite on peut comprendre qu'elle
ait du mal à réussir son examen de
français ce serait pardon de dire comme
ça mais de dire il y a juste un
examen de français et puis c'est tout
nous on dit il y a un examen de français
qui conditionne le titre de séjour mais
il y a aussi énormément de moyens que
vont désormais mettre en place les
services de la République pour que ces
personnes puissent suivre des cours de
français le temps qu'il faudra mais au
bout d'un moment on va demander l'examen
de français mais s'ils n'ont pas on va
pas précariser ces personnes ils
n'auront pas de titre de séjour et donc
du coup il repartiront dans leur pays je
savais qu'on nous assumons le fait que
le titre de séjour désormais c'est c'est
dans ça que c'est une révolution en
partie de cette exode loi et conditionné
pas simplement voir le statut de la
personne par le fait qu'il ait le droit
dans le droit actuel de demander un
titre de séjour mais par le fait
nous on trouve que pour s'intégrer et
notamment je pense que
je pense notamment pour les pour les
femmes qui d'ailleurs ont le moins accès
à la langue et moins en moins accès à
notre culture et qui parfois recréer du
communautarisme d'obligation
d'obligation elle le subissent bien
évidemment parce que la République ne
s'est pas intéressée si je veux dire à
les amener vers me semble-t-il la plus
belle langue du monde pour se faire
comprendre de comprendre les idées de la
République et aller peut-être s'ouvrir
s'ouvrir l'esprit donc oui bah nous nous
disons que après les moyens très
importants qu'on y mettra après l'examen
qu'on imposera si les gens réussissent
pas cet examen et ça vaut pour les
personnes qui demandent de ces jours
comme pour ceux qui m'ont demandé leur
renouvellement y compris pour les
étrangers qui sont sur notre sol je
pense qu'il faut bien comprendre que
c'est une une révolution importante dans
le droit des étrangers que la condition
linguistique il y a des pays qui le font
il y a des pays qui le font vous ne
pouvez pas avoir certains titres de ces
jours dans certains pays anglo-saxons si
vous n'avez pas réussi un examen enfin
je pense que chacun le sait ici donc
évidemment c'est une disposition très
importante et qui fait des barres moi je
comprends très bien et qui est
d'ailleurs assez novatrice en Europe sur
les moyens des préfectures bon on aura
l'occasion de discuter mais ça
renforcement de 570 agents que vous avez
voté dans la dans la loopnie mais aussi
particulièrement je voudrais le dire des
travaux à la fois informatiques la
fameuse AF pour ceux qui s'intéressent
au fonctionnement la direction générale
des étrangers en France qui sera
beaucoup plus efficace et les ETP les
personnes qui aujourd'hui font tout le
travail que j'ai expliqué de répétition
qui n'a pas beaucoup d'intérêt pour la
République pour se concentrer sur les
personnes qui ont plus besoin d'être
avant d'être contrôlés et non monsieur
le sénateur pardon si je me suis mal
exprimé mais il n'y a pas avec le guida
avec la cellule nouvelle il n'y a pas de
moments où l'étranger ne passe plus
devant les associations pour raconter
leur récit il y aura toujours ce moment
évidemment et ce sera toujours le
parcours du demandeur du demandeur
d'asile donc on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler mais je me permets de vous
rassurer sur ce point sur les LR bon les
les ras vous savez ils sont connus dans
votre dans votre département il suffit
de demander de préfet c'est une liste
publiée d'ailleurs j'ai du mal à
comprendre pourquoi vous dites que le
LR1 n'est pas ça pose un problème sur
les parties publiques parce que c'est
Monsieur Jospin qui les a créé le 19
mars 2001 par décret voilà donc c'est
pas un gouvernement de droite ou le
nôtre qui pourrait être considéré comme
étant particulièrement factieux je pense
que si Monsieur Jospin a créé les ras
c'est qu'il est considérer que ça devait
être républicain est conforme conforme
au droit et puis enfin pour Ethias moi
est en train de sortir Schengen moi je
vous réitère le fait que nous on est
totalement prêt on peut le faire demain
matin simplement c'est pas vous que je
vais apprendre que l'Europe c'est pas
que la France il y a plusieurs pays qui
sont pas toujours aussi au rendez-vous
que nous notamment nous avons un
problème vous le savez bien avec nos
amis britanniques qui avaient engagé en
trésor des Schengen et puis entre temps
ils sont devenus à pays tiers donc ça va
poser problème et notamment au port de
Louvre j'en parle beaucoup avec mon
homologue britannique puisque en plus
par ailleurs le port de Douvres pas une
propriété directe du gouvernement
britannique et donc ça passe par une
délégation enfin bref un peu complexe
pour mettre en place le système entrée
sortie Schengen nous avons dit à la
Commission européenne avec les membres
nous avons dit soit on le fait
rapidement donc nous on est prêt et
rapidement c'est à dire quoi c'est à
dire sans doute après la Coupe du monde
de rugby soit on le fait après les JO
parce que qu'est-ce qui se passe quand
on fait l'entrée sortie Schengen on crée
une fiche biométrique pour chacune des
personnes qui va rentrer sur le sol
européen c'est à dire 10 minutes au
minimum
à l'Aubette donc la veille ou l'avant
veille en juin juillet 2023 on va pas
s'amuser à faire 10 minutes par personne
dans les aéroports parisiens alors que
on va pouvoir venir des millions et des
millions de personnes non seulement pour
la vie touristique du pays mais pour les
JO donc ça ce serait thrombose assurée
donc nous on dit on est prêt on le fait
maintenant si on le fait pas maintenant
on le fera peut-être juste après la
Coupe du monde de rugby parce qu'il faut
accepter l'arrivée des gens parlions de
rugby mais si c'est pour nous dire que
les pays seront prêts en juin 2024 la
France dire ah non on attendra après
après les JO donc après septembre 2024
donc on redit et on a redit à la
Commission européenne je fais ces
interventions régulièrement au Conseil
européen que nous nous sommes prêts que
nous attendons les autres et on bouge la
Commission française j'avais vu qui a
été nommée qui a été élu à l'agence
ulisa qui je pense c'est tout à fait
conscient des difficultés des autres de
certains autres pays pour Madame
l'herbier moi je peux être que d'accord
avec vous même Verbier ton sur la
question de droit public et peut-être je
serai monsieur du stop dire un mot sur
la deuxième point sur la vie
professionnelle et sur la vie étudiante
mais vous avez parfaitement raison et
notamment sur les liens avec les pays
producteurs de drogue et qui sont au
trafiquants de drogue on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler sans doute madame stage
joyeux vous posez une question en tout
cas ce qui me concerne sur l'accord et
je terminerai par là plus la question de
Bresse sur l'accord sur les accords
bilatéraux prenons l'accord
franco-algérien c'est une question très
intéressante auquel je me suis beaucoup
intéressé je comprends pourquoi vous
nous dites l'accord franco-algérien qui
grosso modo est un accord fait entre nos
pays en 68 qui prévoit des avances des
avantages et des inconvénients entre la
de discussion avec l'Algérie sur la
question migratoires
avantages pour les Algériens une carte
de résidence spécifique que chacun
connaît avec des droits particuliers qui
sont reconnus aux citoyens algériens
inconvénient il y a des visas tous les
pays comme les pays tiers n'ont pas
forcément de visa que demande la partie
algérienne la même chose que vous le
parlement algérien demande parfois
l'abolition de l'accord franco-algérien
mais pas pour les mêmes raisons parce
que Ie leur ce qu'ils veulent c'est pas
de visa pour venir en France on sait
bien pourquoi il a été fait il a été
fait un moment donné où la France devait
tirer les conclusions des accords
d'Évian jusqu'au bout du fait que
l'Algérie n'était plus la France et donc
avoir un lion un lien particulier avec
non seulement nos amis algériens mais
aussi tous ceux qui avaient des intérêts
des avantages des propriétés dans des
conditions très tumultueuses de
l'histoire entre la France et l'Algérie
pour mettre fin un accord c'est assez
facile encore que l'accord de prévoit
pas sa résiliation cette première
question diplomatique très intéressante
très importante je ne suis pas diplomate
mais du coup on pourrait imaginer que
c'est comme tous les autres accords bon
donc du coup qu'est-ce que c'est si
c'est tous les autres accords
c'est quoi la situation excentée c'est
la France et l'Algérie c'est même pays
c'est la circulation libre et totale
entre nos deux pays donc plus de visa
alors pour réviser l'accord il faut être
deux pays donc il faudrait que nous
renégocions un accord il faut que les
deux parties signent cet accord
aujourd'hui l'actuel d'actualité droit
je me suis beaucoup intéressé à cette
question si nous mettons fin à l'accord
franco-algérien ils ont en imaginant que
la France signe et explique que c'est
plus possible nous reviendrons dans une
communauté ou nous ne pourrions plus
demander de visa au ressentissants
Algériens pour venir sur notre sol
puisque avant la coffre algérien madame
madame madame madame assassin's elle est
pas d'accord puisque nous étions dans
une même communauté nationale
oui mais si nous revenons non mais
écoutez bah écoutez ce sont les très
nombreuses je suis beaucoup intéressé à
cette question je peux vous dire que
l'ensemble des notes de notre diplomatie
confirmé par malheureusement une grande
partie de ceux qui sont extérieurs à
d'autres pays mais qui regardent des
agorat internationaux que dans très
particulier de l'Algérie je pense que
nous aurions aujourd'hui plus atteinte
qui a gagné en revanche qu'il faille
renégocier l'accord il appartient au
chef d'État de le faire avec l'autorité
du Parlement bien évidemment c'est une
question que tout le monde se pose du
côté algérien comme du côté français à
chaque fois qu'on nous rencontrons nos
homologues nous en parle et ça fait très
longtemps il a été plusieurs fois
modifié cet accord peut penser qu'il y a
des avenants peuvent profondément
modifier ses accords la seule difficulté
c'est est-ce qu'ils ont le fait dans des
conditions de communion politique on va
dire que le Président de la République
essaye de faire avec le président teboun
où est-ce qu'on le fait dans une
confrontation bon ça c'est une décision
politique qui n'appartient pas au
ministre remise l'intérieur pour
Monsieur de Bresse il n'y a pas de
disposition de restriction du logement
famil dans notre projet de loi cependant
j'ai eu l'occasion alors sauf à
considérer que évidemment la langue
s'applique et dans ces cas là ça touche
évidemment la langue j'ai entendu la
part de beaucoup de sénateurs du groupe
centriste et du groupe LR proposé des
restrictions d'abord je voulais vous
dire qu'en attendant le débat sénatorial
le gouvernement a pris soin à ce qu'il y
ait des accroches pour que le Parlement
puisse déposer des amendements qui
prévoit sur la section je serai
favorable assez à un moment appartement
évidemment il respecte les principes
conventionnels et constitutionnels mais
je crois que sénateur ne ferait pas
autre chose que de respecter la
Constitution et la convention moi
personnellement je vois trois endroits
dans lequel le Sénat pourrait aller le
premier endroit c'est celui qu'on a tous
vécu quand on était maire c'est-à-dire
les conditions d'accueil du groupement
familial pour accueillir des gens
familiales je sais pas si vous faisiez
ça qu'on étiez mère Monsieur le Maire
mais moi quand j'étais mère je le
faisais je signais moi-même ce que les
citoyens étrangers venaient demander à
la à la mairie et à tester que leur
logement était assez grand qui touchait
au moins euros pour une famille de deux
personnes et que effectivement ils
avaient une situation stable de plus de
18 mois sur le territoire national je
suis pas sûr que tous les maires de
France entre deux soi-dis regardent
expressément cela il faut comme savoir
que pour donner des titres de
regroupement familial la préfecture
s'appuie sur le document délivré par la
mairie la question d'ailleurs de savoirs
sont gêner les représentants des
collectivités locales peut-être est-ce
quelque chose que les mairies peuvent
pas dans certaines conditions faire bon
c'est une question que l'on peut qu'on
peut se poser en tout cas nous délivrons
du repas familial que lorsque les maires
en tout cas leur service attestent de ce
document la question se pose si ce
document doit être mieux vérifié
premièrement petit veut dire double un
double contre ça afin que ça risque de
préfecture empêche ici le clientélisme
électoral là la difficulté de dire non à
une famille que l'on connaît quand on
est élu bon c'est une question qu'on a
eu sur les lieux de culte dans d'autres
circonstances et deuxièmement est-ce que
1800 euros pour deux personnes ça suffit
et est-ce que le logement à taille
suffisante c'est assez suffisant pour
être défini dans la loi
parce que quand on accueille quelqu'un
de l'extérieur ça paraît pas anormal de
demander peut-être davantage de revenus
ou peut-être davantage de commodité ou
davantage de présence sur le territoire
national donc si le Sénat allait vers
des modifications qui diraient un
logement plus grand des rémunérations
plus fortes et surtout une condition de
présence plus longue soit territoire
national ça me paraîtrait de bon sens et
non contraire à la Constitution à la
convention à la grosse européenne des
droits de l'homme mais peut-être les
limiter le groupement familial le
deuxième sujet c'est que pour ceux qui
bénéficient de la protection
internationale il y a des possibilités
de regroupement familial de
réunification familiale comme on dit en
droit mais qui vont loin c'est-à-dire
que c'est pas simplement les frères et
soeurs il se peut que y ait des gens
dans une conception très large de la
famille des demi-frères et demi soeurs
des voilà des gens qui peut-être sont un
peu loin de la vision familiale telle
que le droit français défini qui sont
acceptés et quand on donne l'asile à
quelqu'un faut-il le donner alors qu'on
donne à sa famille ça me paraît pas
choquant bien évidemment faut-il donner
à sa famille au sens très large du terme
je pense que si le Sénat puisque j'ai eu
depuis quelques mois m'intéressait à la
question de ce projet de loi des abus
incontestablement considéré qu'il
fallait limiter son bon familial à la
stricte famille en défense en
définissant c'est quoi la famille au
sens français du terme je pense que nous
y gagnerions et nous limiterions ainsi
cette difficulté et le troisième sujet
il me semble que ça pourrait être
l'attestation linguistique ou
l'attestation des valeurs de la
République y compris pour ceux qui ont
des visas de ruban familial puisque
aujourd'hui vous demandez à quelqu'un
la langue est le respect des vers de la
République mais quand il sera là depuis
18 mois et qu'il aura un logement
suffisant 1800 euros de revenu et un
accompagnement
comment dirais-je de
présence sur le territoire national de
18 mois vous demandez pas à ces à sa
femme à son mari à ses parents à ses
enfants les mêmes exigences est-ce que
le Sénat pourrait dire bah voilà on
demande là aussi le la langue et là
aussi les valeurs de la République quoi
donc ça ça me paraît de notre point de
vue des dispositions qui pourraient
limiter le groupement familial sans être
contraire à la Constitution contraire à
la course et que font certains autres
pays par exemple
je crois qu'il y avait une question
madame Boyer
attendait la réponse sur les jeunes
ma question sur les mineurs isolés
c'était sur l'accès à la nationalité
française alors que ces personnes sont
rentrées via des trafiquants d'êtres
humains sont en situation irrégulière
sont à la charge des départements
parfois au détriment je dois dire des
enfants que nous devons prendre en
charge de l'enfance de l'enfance en
souffrance maltraitée donc je voudrais
savoir si dans le projet de loi vous
allez faire en sorte que ces personnes
ne puissent pas accéder comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui quasi pas
automatiquement mais très fréquemment à
la nationalité française une fois qu'ils
sont majeurs alors j'ai pas répondu à la
fois la deuxième question de stage
Brignoud et à vos deux questions madame
la satrice vous en aviez trois les
mineurs je pense avoir répondu alors moi
j'ai pas de connaissances de de mineur
qui est arrivé à l'âge majeur deviennent
français quasi systématiquement donc en
revanche qui disait quasi
systématiquement des des titres de
séjour parce que ils sont depuis un
certain temps sur le territoire national
c'est tout à fait vrai d'ailleurs le
président du conseil départemental le
l'Essonne m'a interpellé sur difficulté
de la loi dite taquée des personnes qui
désormais venu mineur isolés non
seulement le département doit les
protéger mais que pour les deux années
qui suivent leur minorité ils doivent
désormais aussi puisqu'une sorte de
difficulté en loi attaquer le Conseil
d'État a fait une décision qui
appliquent la loi donc ça pose un
problème donc je pense que c'est plus
une question à mon avis de titre de
séjour quasiment donné en attendant une
éventuelle expulsion je ne l'ai pas en
tête mais si vous avez des cas je les
regarderai que je me permets de vous le
dire parce que j'ai fait un rapport
lorsque j'étais député sur ce sujet et
les départements interrogés m'ont dit
qu'ils accompagnaient pour qu'ils
accèdent
je veux pas dire systématiquement parce
que c'est peut-être le terme est trop
trop
enfin pour qu'ils accèdent le plus
rapidement possible la nationalité
française
très bien volontiers peut-être sur la
deuxième question madame la sénatrice
monsieur le Président sur les passeurs
donc merci de nous remercier de
reprendre votre proposition je pense que
contre les passeurs tout est bonnes
volontés sont bonnes je voudrais dire
qu'on crée une circonstance aggravante
générale donc ça ne concerne pas que les
personnes que vous évoquez ça concerne
vraiment au sens large tous les passeurs
y compris les les complices y compris ce
qui exploite je vois d'ailleurs dire
dans le Sénat que nous avons créé un
office de préjudiciaire spécifique qu'on
appelle l'autre lime avec 140 officiers
de police judiciaires c'est vraiment à
mon avis pour dire qu'il y a
l'application du droit sera faite grâce
à cette office et puis enfin
je voudrais dire à Madame staff Brugnot
que sur la question des médecins qui
n'appliquerait pas la loi eux-mêmes
l'article
412,7 que nous créerions dans l'article
13 du projet de loi est extrêmement
clair l'étranger qui sollicite un
document de séjour s'engage à respecter
la liberté personnelle la liberté
d'expression et de conscience l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes la
dignité de la personne humaine la devise
et les symboles de la République au sens
de l'article de la Constitution et à ne
pas se prévaloir de ses croyances
convictions pour s'affranchir des règles
communes régissant les relations entre
les services publics et les particuliers
ça concerne tout le monde les patients
comme les médecins
merci monsieur le Président peut-être de
manière télégraphique sur trois points
d'abord pour dire que pour ce qui
concerne les plateformes et plus
largement que les plateformes la
question des auto-entrepreneurs et des
entreprises individuelles c'est un vrai
c'est une vraie faille que nous
connaissons aujourd'hui et il n'est pas
acceptable que des personnes en
situation irrégulière puissent d'une
certaine manière créer une entreprise
individuelle ou se créer comme
auto-entrepreneur et ainsi exercer une
activité qui devient régulière pourquoi
ça n'est pas acceptable parce que
lorsque les personnes concernées pour
une raison pour une autre son objet d'un
OCP délivré par les services de ministre
de l'Intérieur il est devient logique à
la fois pour la personne concernée et
parfois pour les juges qui sont amenés à
examiner tel ou telle recours de dire
que l'État ne peut pas prétendre ne pas
connaître découvrir la situation
irrégulière sur le territoire de tel ou
telle personne alors que dans le même
temps par l'existence d'une entreprise
individuelle il y a eu perception de
cotisation et régulièrement aussi
d'impôt sur le revenu du fait du
prélèvement à la source forfaitaire en
tout cas des avances forfaitaires
prévues dans le cadre du prélèvement à
la source donc c'est une vraie volonté
de tarir un flux qui nourrit cette
situation de personnes en situation
irrégulière mais avec l'exercice d'une
activité régulière beaucoup d'entre eux
notamment pour les auto-entrepreneurs
sont concernés ou peuvent être concernés
par le travail de plateforme et en
réalité derrière la question des
plateformes dans ce domaine là il y a
deux sujets il y a le sujet des
personnes en situation irrégulière dans
la plateforme découvre l'irrégularité de
la situation et procède à une
déconnexion et il y a peut-être de
manière plus régulière encore plus
fréquente des personnes qui en réalité
exercent un travail sur une plateforme
non pas en situation irrégulière sur le
papier si je peux dire mais avec des
alias ce qui renvoie aussi à d'autres
difficultés pour accompagner cela nous
avons malgré tout des charges sociales
avec les plateformes pour que la
déconnexion puisse être annoncée et
accompagner autant que possible mais les
personnes qui sont en situation
régulière le reste elle doit faire
l'objet d'un traitement de leur
situation en fonction de la régularité
de leur séjour et des causes
d'irrégularité de l'irrégularité et
lorsqu'ils question pour nous de laisser
perdurer la possibilité de créer une
entreprise ou une autre entreprise pour
des personnes qui n'ont pas de raison
d'être sur le territoire vous avez
évoqué la question de la circulaire
valse monsieur Lecomte celle-ci concerne
pour à peu près 7000 cas par an des
admissions exceptionnelles au séjour
pour des motifs économiques avec des
caractéristiques qui peuvent en couper
une partie de ceux et celles qui sont
concernées par l'article 3 tel que nous
le prévoyons mais pour 22 à 23000 cas ce
sont des admissions exceptionnelles de
ces jours pour des motifs familiaux qui
sont prononcés dans le cadre de la
circulaire valse c'est la raison pour
laquelle les deux dispositifs ne sont
pas nécessairement antagoniques par
contre ça me fait un lien avec les
interrogations de Madame sajouinho la
circulaire valse aujourd'hui c'est 7000
régularisations pour des activités
économiques dans la moitié en
Île-de-France et comme je disais tout à
l'heure à Monsieur bonnekin et Madame
Jourda il vaut mieux à nos yeux que la
reconnaissance du droit à un séjour et
donc la régularisation de travailleurs
en situation irrégulière mais une
activité professionnelle régulière sur
le territoire soit déterminé par des
critères fixés et définis par
législateur plutôt que par des critères
qui à l'exception des critères
d'ancienneté tels qu'ils sont prévus
dans la circulaire relèvent d'une
appréciation discrétionnaire préfecture
par préfecture et c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs cette appréciation
discrétionnelle motivée par les
difficultés inhérentes à chaque
territoire qui explique que la moitié
des cas sont concentrés sur la région
parisienne alors qu'on savons qu'il y a
des difficultés par ailleurs vous m'avez
ensuite interrogé madame la sénatrice
sur la question des métiers de tension
et vous m'avez dit mais finalement dans
un territoire comme le mien tous les
métiers sont en tension et d'une
certaine manière je vous le confirme je
vous le confirme mais par un autre
raisonnement vous n'imaginez pas le
nombre de fédérations professionnelles
qui nous contactent qui nous contactent
directement au s'inquiéter et s'assurer
que leur métier sera bien dans la liste
ce à quoi je réponds que ce n'est pas
nous qui allons décider mais mettez dans
la liste mais bien l'appareil
statistique avec la définition d'un
niveau de tension et donc la liste des
métiers en tension existe elle a été
créée par la loi il y a plusieurs années
elle a fait l'objet d'une publication
régulière et nous allons lancer ce
processus de révision qui s'appuie sur
les créfopes comme des régionaux pour
l'emploi la formation professionnelle et
sur la Paris statistique du ministère
pour tenir compte à la fois des
difficultés de recrutement et de la
présence parfois très forte d'étrangers
non communautaire qui justifie parfois
une tension un peu moindre mais sans la
présence de cette manœuvre non
communautaire la tension serait au-delà
de l'attention et ça serait une
incapacité pour le secteur de
fonctionner il y a des demandes de
fédérations professionnelles dans la
matière il y a des demandes
d'organisation syndicale les trois
principales pour nous citer que les
premières dans leur protocolaire la CFDT
la CGT Force Ouvrière souhaite même que
les travailleurs qui exercent dans des
secteurs économiques pas nécessairement
attention face au lieu d'une
régularisation de plein droit c'est pas
vers ce n'est pas
que nous allons puisque nous fixons un
certain nombre de critères mais il y a
vraiment une volonté partagée de
faciliter et compris c'est parcours de
régularisation et nous essayons de poser
des critères pour que ce soit lisibles
et évaluable par le Parlement vous avez
ensuite fait deux remarques la première
concernant
le fait que les métiers les secteurs
seraient peut-être moins intentions si
les rémunérations étaient ajustées à la
hausse or il se trouve que un des
secteurs les plus intentions et au sein
duquel nous avons le plus de demandes
pour élargir la liste des métiers
concernés au sein du secteur un secteur
qui s'exprime j'ai parlé de lui MIH tout
à l'heure pour dire à long plus loin en
matière de régularisation et facilitant
facilitant en plus les procédures
d'entrée sur le territoire de nouveaux
étrangers non communautaire pour occuper
des métiers dans notre secteur c'est
justement un secteur le secteur
hôtellerie qui a fait restauration dans
lequel la négociation des partenaires
sociaux a amené la revalorisation des
minimum conventionnels la plus forte
c'est 16% à l'issue de la période de
covid des tensions de recrutement qui
sont intervenus maintenant un peu plus
d'un an le secteur HCR dans sa
négociation collective a augmenté les
niveaux de rémunération conventionnelle
de 16%. et c'est malgré tout ce secteur
qui concentre peut-être parmi les plus
fortes difficultés de tension et qui
nous dans les interpellations dont nous
ont l'objet et le plus demandeur en
matière de régularisation
d'accompagnement et je le répète de
possibilités supplémentaire d'entrer sur
le territoire ce que nous n'avons pas
envisager envisager à ce stade enfin il
y a un dernier point j'en termine par là
vous vous craignez que cette possibilité
de régularisation par le quelques
milliers de personnes par an ça n'est
pas quelque chose gigantesque mais que
cette régularisation soit une forme de
frappe à bassala je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure en réponse à Madame et Monsieur
les rapporteurs je pense que c'est tout
l'inverse que c'est le fait d'être en
situation irrégulière sur un territoire
qui rend vulnérable notamment face à des
employeurs qui ne sont pas tous très
attentif ou très délicat je cherche les
mots les plus adéquates nous avons des
cas c'est très pragmatique mais nous
sommes saisis de salariés qui sont
employés sur des contrats à temps
partiel à mi-temps qui sont payés à
mi-temps et qui en réalité travaillent
beaucoup plus mais étant en situation
irrégulière sur le territoire et n'ayant
que cet emploi déclaré si je peux dire
son contrainte d'accepter cette
situation et le fait de pouvoir donner
une sécurité juridique à la fois
l'employeur parce que je le répète bien
souvent l'employeur ne sait pas la
situation irrégulière sans salarié et
aux salariés ça garantit l'application
des minimum des niveaux de rémunération
conventionnelle ça garantit évidemment
l'application du salaire minimum et
c'est plutôt avec un effet inverse à la
trappe à bas salaire par rapport au
maintien d'un certain nombre de
personnes dans des situations qu'on peut
qualifier comme des situations de
vulnérabilité et donc c'est vraiment
avec cet objectif là que nous
travaillons et j'espère que les débats
que nous aurons dans l'hémicycle
permettront d'en convaincre un maximum
merci monsieur le ministre à côté s'il
n'y a pas d'autres questions
et je crois qu'il y en a eu beaucoup en
tous les cas et beaucoup d'explications
nous arrivons en termes de notre
commission il me reste à vous remercier
messieurs pour votre présence rappelez
au commissaire que la Commission nous
rapporteur présent leur rapport le 15 en
commission le 15 mars et que la séance
aura lieu à partir du 27 exactement du
28 qui est un mardi sur ma part enfin je
vous redonne rendez-vous à tous les
commissaires aux lois demain matin à 9h
dans notre salle de réunion préférée
merci à vous